uh and then uh get into the process we
will take our roll call and get in the
process on how we're gonna move today
seeing we do have a couple bills which
we have to make a decision on uh that
have come back to us from the senate
whether we're going to concur non-concur
or non-concur and request a committee of
conference
so as chair of the house education
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of cobit 19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically electronically
this is a public uh meeting and today we
are going to be uh executing uh senate
bills which we have in our possession
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-day
anyone who has a problem accessing the
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us we have
jennifer four who is our res uh
committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call quote
let's start the meeting by taking roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
uh barbara are you able to
speak out loud are you good with that
you i i can't hear you you have to
how's that
yes i'm here in the committee room
with committee members
representative cardelli
here in the committee room
representative boehm
representative notter
i saw you bouncing around representative
lakes
you're in the committee room
representative moffitt
here in the committee room
representative hobson
here at the committee room happy to see
you
thank you
representative andres
here home alone in salisbury
representative ford
president my office in chester alone
representative land
here in the committee room welcome back
thanks
representative miler
here in kentucky new hampshire in my
home and i'm here as are hundreds of
other granite staters who are also
able to participate in the legislative
representative luno
dave luno participating remotely just
like thousands of granite staters have
done this year to express their opinions
on on our work
granting an unprecedented level of
government transparency and public
engagement
representative shaw here alone in
manchester
representative cornell
here at home in manchester and glad to
representative tanner
here uh with my rescue dog raven who may
bark um i'm located in sunapee new
hampshire and i am very grateful
to be able to zoom into this meeting and
share
my um story and my committee meeting
with hundreds of other people who can
zoom in as well thank you
representative ellison
uh president i'm home alone here in
concord
representative mullen
i am here in bedford having been
promoted from the basement
along with my laptop and happy to see
everyone this morning on zoom
representative
porter
this is representative porter i'm home
in hillsborough um
my husband is in the house but not in
the room with me and i'm glad to see all
your faces this morning and welcome back
whatever
thank you
representative woodcock
welcome barbara glass here on the screen
representing woodcock from sena conway
new hampshire with my dog we'll be in
and out
and
enjoying the opportunity to
engage with this committee remotely as
many of our granite staters have done
throughout the process of uh honest and
upfront dialogue
full house
well thank you very much
we're ready to move on uh
representative vlad could i have a point
of personal privilege please
go ahead
i need to register this we have received
some
amendments to bills
that have not been considered prior to
this by this committee
and i want to say how disappointed i am
we had a work session a week ago in
which there was ample opportunity for
members of this committee
to present their concerns to the
committee so we could have a
conversation prior
to the receipt of
these amendments
one of the particularly one of the
members was silent
who
throughout that work session that has
proposed some of these amendments
this is not the way this committee has
worked in the past this is the first
time in nine years
that i have seen some of these
regressive
amendments come forth in the 11th hour
of our deliberations
this is not a transparent process
this is not a way that we should do
business
and i object
to the process that is going forth today
on these particular bills that are
controversial
and i would hope that in the future this
committee would be more prudent as it
looks at the work that we need to do we
have not done this in the past rick and
you know this
representative luna for example
has forwarded to you
the amendments that he is considering
ask for your approval on those prior to
his sending these out to the committees
many of these bills that we are now
considering these amendments that we
were considering came into the 11th hour
without any notice to us and i object to
that process because that's not the way
this committee has done work
thank you very much represent my own um
we at our last hearing or last time we
were here together on the zoom we
discussed the fact that we were
encouraging people to put
amendments in
and that we ask that all those
amendments be forwarded two folks prior
to this exact session today i believe
that was done
so with that we're going to go ahead
with our meeting today
and the first thing i want to do is look
at the two bills which we've had
submitted to us from the senate the to
concur or not concur i'd like to get
that out of the way here so we can then
get these down to the clerk's office
i sent information out on this to folks
uh yesterday
you've also can notice that uh the bills
which are coming to us from the senate
as they've been amended appears in our
calendar they've been in the calendar
for the last several weeks
so the first bill we will take up is the
lesser number hb 320
uh this is a bill requiring a civics
competency assessment as a high school
graduation requirement
uh what this does it changes one portion
of that bill it changes the effective
date from 60 days following passage to
july 1
this remembers if we're not going to
have a long debate on this it's where
you just provide the chair here your
position on that bill whether you feel
that we should concur with the
recommendations coming to us
whether we're not to concur with that
recommendation
or number three we're going to concur
but we see that the bill could be or
that amendment and we could work on that
and come out by the positive
recommendation so that would be
non-concur and recommend a committee of
conference
so um i'd like to just take a poll of
the committee members to find out where
we are on this
um representative moffat seeing that you
are the prime sponsor of that bill
um do you have any feeling on that
uh thank you mr chair i would simply
concur with the amendment that the
the uh the prime sponsor bill has said
that now we have as a committee have
also passed this bill obviously
is there
any opposition to what has been
suggested by uh representative often
i'm not seeing any hands up or
waiving or anything like that so that's
without a mark down concur with the
senate on that bill let's go to the next
bill
uh this bill is relative to offenses
that prevent employment in a school
and the changes that i see and
i did it briefly the other day a couple
days back so um
i believe that what it does it
changes uh one portion where we have
misdemeanor to felony
that was in
part one section one of the of the bill
the other portions that i see it's
adding
uh for charter public schools
uh the proposed charter school
application shall be presented for
approval directly to the state board of
education by the absence for the
prospective charter public school the
content of such application shall
conform to the requirements set forth in
rsa which i just mentioned the felony
and that adds in a component underneath
rsa 194b roman 2
uh double e
uh you can see that on the back side and
so it's just putting that uh statutory
requirement or where it could be such
punish policy may also include language
stating that any person has been
convicted of any
rehab uh
misdemeanor it's now been upgraded to a
felony or any of our list of felonies
shall not be hired
comments represent how do you feel about
that
uh well i'm the prime sponsor on that
bill
representative vlad so i do appreciate
the uh
point of order to speak
um
432 in its original form as this
committee knows uh went through
relatively easily as a request from the
department of education to include human
trafficking to the list of 189 offenses
we currently we commonly call them
section 5 offenses
that would prohibit somebody from being
credentialed in new hampshire to teach
i don't think any of us had an objection
to that it went through easily
when the bill went to the senate i
presented as prime sponsor and uh there
was discussion
regarding senate bill 81 which was
senator ruth ward's bill
that included the section on charter
school employees
being held to the teacher code of ethics
and conduct
and at that time
senator khan
presented the notion and the amendment
that
he agreed with senator ward
and felt that if
people were amenable they would amend
432 to include the provision that
charter school teachers who are in fact
employed public school teachers
would also uh be held to that code of
conduct and ethics
uh were a couple of different places
where that had to be referenced as you
mentioned as ee
i have absolutely no problem with uh
charter school teachers
being held to the
ethical and conduct standards of our
traditional public school teachers and i
would ask that people uh concur with
this
is there any objection to what
is uh suggesting
i don't see any hands up from ceremony i
think we're good to go with it so we
will concur
with the
amendments made by the
by the senate and i concur and agree
that all teachers need to be held to
this level of expectation
and conduct
and that's why we spent many years with
this particular instrument the code of
conduct and professional behavior
so thank you very much that so we have
for me i'd like to say well
thank you for bringing this up and bring
back a long tradition in the past that
was not done last term
but i'm giving
everybody on the committee a chance to
speak
on senate bills that were amended so
we've all worked on that for several
months here i think we all deserve the
opportunity to have him put on
okay with that we're going to move into
the bills which we have set up on the
dock today to be exact
uh this and we'll start moving through
these bills
is a bill relative to the degree
granting authority of signum university
you all know that we have
hb 513 which is the same identical bill
it's been passed by the house of the
senate and it's enrolled right now
represent like us for a motion on that
bill please i make a motion to ipl
19.
and represent
seconds that motion so we have a motion
to itl
uh sb19 the sigmund bill
is there any discussion
i think you pretty much said it rick
okay he already passed so let's move on
okay so then what we're going to do is
have a roll call on that please madam
clerk are you with us there barb
hang in there
can you hear me yes we can
oh okay
all right this is on um
senate bill 44
19 i'm sorry
19. my apologies
bear with me
um
yes
representative bowm
representative notter
yes
representative lycus
representative moffett
yes representative hobson yes
representative andres
yes
representative ford
representative leon
yes
representative soti yes
representative miler yes representative
luno
yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
yes
representative mullen yes
representative lay
representative porter yes
representative porter
representative woodcock yes
representative ladd
yes
20-0
so we'll put that on consent no
no
i'm going to do a minority report on the
itl
um i'm sorry
to interrupt you guys
i'm not sure if you can
have a minority report if it's 20 to
[Music]
i think you'd have to vote no
okay we have a
is there anybody else who wants to
okay so um we have a
1901 vote obviously then you are
suggesting that it not go on the consent
detectives that what you're saying
represent lino correct i'm suggesting
that only because i want to do a
minority uh report on the minority
reason why
uh an itl is um
uh is warranted which i think is
okay um
so we'll move ahead we'll put that on
the regular calendar
not on the consent it's 1911.
i'm really sorry to interrupt again but
we would have to have two different
um
two different motions i believe you can
include
both reasonings within the same
report but i don't believe we can have
two reports
with the same motion
so so point of order on that
i thought often times there was uh there
was
otpa motions
yeah if you have an amendment yeah
see i've never heard this either before
when we've had a 20 to 00 minutes 19 to
1.
and
i mean there would have to be an
alternate motion
right
on an itl right whenever we do up the
report we have to say what our
alternative motion is
let's see
um
i mean i'm
[Music]
i mean really rick all i'm trying to do
is um is express
the um the the
the house democratic caucus position
on on the reason why we do not believe
uh signum university should be granted
degree granting authority
um
represent luna i think you thoroughly
did that when we had a discussion of
that when it hit the house floor
um
previously when we had the previous bill
that dealt with the same same issue
what was it hp
one three
if it's palatable to the committee the
multiple reasons for voting itl could be
incorporated into one report
but that's up to the writer
of of the committee report i'd be okay
with that
and if so i would change my vote back to
um
yes on the itl and uh and and okay with
consent
representative should be the writer of
that report are you as general forces
compatible to
by incorporating some language uh
the language that was expressed
you ditto what i had said
yeah all i was going to report was this
what do you guys think
i i think the motion is you know that
the it's an ought to pass basic motion
so
i don't understand why we're writing in
two motions within one report
especially since this is already an
enrolled bill i don't know i'm not not
saying you need to do two motions in the
report but uh but to express the the
committee's rationale for the itl i
don't think is as simple as as um
it could say something like some members
of the committee felt x and some members
of the committee
agreed with the committee recommendation
i've never done this before
miss before and i'm not really uh
we we had a vote which was supported
this bill
uh being
itl
i'm basically including a minority
report within
i agree my itl report and that's here
i'm not going to support that
i'm not going to tell the person to make
the motion how to write that report
could it be pulled from the consent
calendar and then somebody speak to it
that's exactly what can happen that can
always be done that can be done i think
that's the option for representing luna
as the vote
can be pulled
and he can
express his uh
his concern
mr chair could could uh
an interim study be an alternate
motion
we have an identical bill
which has been passed by the house
passed by the senate
and now it's enrolled so it's on its way
also in previous years
[Music]
university
so i'm not saying he's i'm not speaking
for him right now because i have spoken
to him on uh on uh 513 specifically
so um
represent porter you have your hand up
i do
i i don't consent to putting it on
consent
okay so we can we can put on the regular
calendar uh
19-1
you also then represent porters as
voting in the negative
are in the positive
see
i'm not i'm not changing my vote
but if it goes on the consent calendar
and then needs to be pulled from the
consent calendar
it will be at the end of a long session
day
if it doesn't go on consent it will come
up in the usual time and i'm requesting
that it come up in the usual time in
if i'm not able to do a it sounds like
i'm not going to be able to do
a
minority report is that correct
that's correct
in in that case
then i'll stick with my itl
but i agree with representative porter
okay so it's are you changing flipping
the tools back because we have if i'm
not able to write a if you're not going
to let me write a minority report on it
then and and we didn't have an
opportunity to offer an alternative
motion because the itl motion was taken
first
then um
um i'm not sure what other alternative i
have
so we'll put this bill on a 20-0
vote
on the regular calendar
i mean if you have another motion
no there's one emotion that's going to
come out and you've already me
but i mean
at least if you did the one he has to
list what his other motion would be but
it doesn't have another motion that's
why we're not having it right before
right
it's there's no majority
is your hand's still up or are you just
so we put that
represent shaw you're reporting this now
as uh 20 to 1 0
yes
okay and it will be
okay uh with that we're going to move to
the next bill which i'm going to discuss
and that's sb 135 and i want to
represent for a motion
well i'm sure mr chair on uh sv135 i'd
like to make the motion to retain this
this bill
is there a second
represent leon you seconded it so we
have
uh emotions on the table to retain 135
made by
representative moffatt and second by
representative leon
we're open to discussion we will turn to
the maker do you care to speak on that
representative
sure mr twisted chair there's a lot to
this and i know others
i'm sure we'll have some um some
comments i simply want to say that some
elements and some issues brought up in
sb 135 were now already
covered and addressed in other measures
which means that that
this bill is currently structured could
create some um some redundancy and maybe
some confusion
so retention is the best option at this
time in my view
russ and leon i agree with that analysis
this was already incorporated
and so it makes the most sense to retain
this
okay it's open to further discussion
represent porter
thank you mr chair i'm
again this is ignorance from the topic
however it seems to me that this bill is
very important to school districts right
now i know that my school district has
sent a letter of support for this bill
passage um
when
it was heard in the senate
so i'm i'm concerned if it's retained by
the time it gets worked on some
districts might be in a real crisis
situation and i'm wondering if you can
for the discussion on that
great mrexcel leon thank you mr chair i
actually was reached out to by the chair
of my school board as well about this
bill and discussing it and looking at
the language in the budget the chair of
the dairy school board was was
comfortable with the budget language um
and i believe that this is already
addressed
so it makes more sense to retain it
rather than killing the body
and in addition we have retained hb 608
which is an advocacy funding bill
and
and we have uh
taken the position that that this uh
whole process of the funding formula
which was studying for the last year and
a half or so
and um at 608 which i accepted your
argument
okay um
so that we will uh by emotional retain
we have some amending language uh that
is
language which we should be aware of and
go through the hearing process
um
that will help us deal with 608 and that
funding formula
and there is a difference in how we
perceive this still within within the
house
we did pass 242 and that is a different
perspective although it does have many
similar components of the costing of an
adequate education
further discussion
representative uh
life has to have your hand up yeah i do
i just wanted to very much thank
representative luno for
the
information
the charts and whatever that you made i
find them very useful and i really
appreciate your work in doing that
and i think
as we digest this
this will be very useful in trying to
figure this out
in the future it's good good information
and
i just wanted to reiterate yes i know we
need to take care of our school
districts
but that's what sb2 does so
thank you
further discussion represent luna
thank you very much mr chair so um first
of all i i don't have any information
that says uh house bill 2 is going to
take care of um of districts and the um
particularly for fy 22
and
house bill 2 is passed by the house
does provide some um
it eliminates some
of
100 million dollars of
statewide education property tax in fy
23 but but doesn't provide um
relief in fy 22 as a result of pandemic
related enrollment uh
changes that that occurred during the
school year that we're finishing uh
right now and um
um and you know in specif specifically
that uh pro it's over 45 million dollars
um uh affects some uh districts all
across the state who um who are not in
fact going to be seeing such a dramatic
uh drop in enrollment
and um and would
uh would in fact have to bear those
costs on the on the local property
taxpayers so that's that's right out of
the gun
a uh a 45 million dollar property tax
hike uh for everybody what hb2 does uh
specifically and i want to um i want to
be really clear on this um is this
provides
um
it does reduce the statewide education
property tax by 100 million dollars and
then it directs an additional it's over
17 million dollars to the wealthiest
community
the wealthiest
property wise communities across the
state so what you'd see in in house bill
2 as passed by the the republican uh
house
is you'd see the ad the average or the
median property in fact the the biggest
um tax cut goes to residents of
newcastle which who would see an average
or at least for the median property in
newcastle over a one thousand dollar
reduction in um in property taxes
uh going down the list the number two
would be rye
and then hale's location and then
newington and portsmouth and new london
moultonborough's in there waterville
valleys um
in the in the top page and at the very
bottom um you're gonna see um towns like
um
uh
and again only only seeing you know a
paltry 50 cent relief on the tax bill in
fy 23 only um i'm prepared to offer
amendments that uh that that go the
other way entirely and um and would use
that 100 million dollars that um that
republicans put into the the hb2
uh again that benefit the
property wealthiest communities across
the state
and direct that on a need-based
formula much like we did in house bill
from two years ago and it would not just
affect fy23
but it would affect fy 22
the coming school year as well as fy23
and um and and in fact
you know based on the formula you know
um looking at at
where this st where the state money
would be directed you'd actually see um
berlin seeing an fy22 it would the tax
reduction would begin in fy 22 and
obviously be and it would be there in fy
23 of almost four dollars per thousand
uh result resulting in a um and a
property tax reduction of over 250
dollars on the median price home in
berlin um so they're at the top of the
list immediately followed by lisbon with
almost a 500
um tax reduction on the median priced
home claremont with over 400 reduction
on a median priced home charlestown with
almost a four over
380 reduction on the median priced home
um in fact pittsfield's in the top 10
with nearly a 500 reduction on the
median priced home of 150 000
potential tax rate uh reduction of three
almost three dollars per thousand 299
uh yielding a um
a reduction in real and property taxes
paid
in pittsfield
by by almost 450 dollars you know i
could keep going on winchester newport
penacook allenstown brookline boston uh
northfield haverhill there's haverhill
right there with over 200
um reduction in um and property taxes
paid on the median priced home so you
know we're sticking with with hb2
um uh haverhill would see a actually
they do see something they get a 62
reduction in fy 23 on the median priced
home as opposed to
um what i said the 200 reduction both in
fy 22 and fy23 so they'd save over 400
over the two years as opposed to 62
dollars just in fy 23. so i mean
you know one of the things that came out
of the school funding commission work
rick and you were there for this
um is is let's use state money where
it's needed most and and i just don't
see that in in in house bill 2. it's
completely opposite that
and um and it's it's it's egregious and
and for people that profess to be
you know people that are again against
government waste
come on i mean house bill 2 is
the the particularly the way the way
school funding is being done and and and
and um and and you know sweetheart tax
breaks are being cut it's all about
government waste it's directing state
funds to where they're not needed and
the amendments that that i talked about
last week i talked about during the
hearing are all about directing our
precious state resources to where
they're needed most so this
what what what's being done here is just
you know i think a travesty against the
uh
granite staters and and taxpayers all
across the state and you know i was
gonna i was gonna introduce this a
little bit later i'll make sure i send a
copy to
all the members on the committee but um
but the senate did receive a um a letter
from the the jim o'brien who's the chair
of the hopkinton school board and you
may know him because he's also a
lobbyist and works for a lot of
republican causes
and um and he writes in this letter and
again i do want this to be included in
the senate bill 135 file that and i'm
quoting from jim's letter here aside
from political ideology we failed to
understand why the legislature would
undertake this unprecedented action to
censor local school districts it is
striking that the house rather than
focus on providing students and
communities with the resources needed to
provide an adequate education or address
the educational funding gap associated
with covid19 has instead used the budget
process to interfere with local control
of education and freedom
we hope that the senate finance
committee will use its budget process to
focus on providing resources to support
student learning and provide local
property tax relief right and then
rather than fighting a fictitious
culture war our students and communities
deserve better and so
um
you know i i think a vote to retain this
bill is a vote to kill
this bill essentially certainly for fy
22 it is which this bill focuses on if
you're going to retain it it's not going
to do anything um uh
a so
a vote to retain it is uh is clearly a
vote against um uh property taxpayers
across the state uh in in in particular
in our hardest hit um uh most vulnerable
communities
and um and and so i would encourage
everybody to vote against the retain
motion it's ill-advised uh i'm i'm glad
we're doing this via zoom i hope lots of
people are watching i know there's some
media reporting out on this i hope it's
widely reported and and i hope state
representatives are accountable for
their votes
uh thank you mr chair
i would concur with uh representative
luno here
the this is a this committee
is responsible for dealing with
public policy regarding education
particularly the funding of education
by retaining this bill
it basically is saying we're not ready
to deal with this
we've been dealing with this forever
but representative luna's amendments
provide
is a clear statement of where this
committee should be as it relates to
property tax relief funding of schools
etc schools cannot wait another year
we're dealing with a fiscal year that's
coming up that needs to have this kind
of
proposals put forth in a direct kind of
a way that can be incorporated into the
budget i i really hope this committee
will reject the retention
motion before us so that we can deal
with the amendments that representative
luna has so
aggressively and uh worked
hard to try to provide information to
this committee so that they can in fact
make a decision and we need to do that
now for the sake of the communities that
thank you very much uh
representative thank you thank you thank
you mr chair
i am curious if
the other representatives have read
section 44 1 of house bill 2.
the language in there is almost exactly
what is in senate bill 135 however it is
more clear for your reference that's on
page 22 lines 30 through 37 the language
of the bill itself
which has a fiscal note was incorporated
in the budget i i know that i'm new but
i don't understand how we'd be able to
take up amendments that would need a
fiscal note when the budget has already
left the house is that something that
would even be possible
representative
mr chair did you say that that's not
possible
yeah it is possible
thank you thank you for correcting
yourself you're welcome
represent anderson
thank you mr speaker
i
am in favor of retaining this bill i am
all for adequate education and monies
but i think we really need to ascertain
what districts need what what money
so far this year
the government has funded over 650
million dollars
to the schools for colbin
pre right now 350 million are going to
be given out by the state of new
hampshire to school districts
and for next year i'm
i don't think we have accurate figures
on everything and i'll tell you why i
come from a school district that's not
considered a rich school district
hello
but they are going
to receive
oh us taxpayers are going to receive
a fund balance of approximately 2
million dollars
so if this kind of fun balance is going
on in my school districts what's going
on in other school districts and i i
just think we need to ascertain who
really needs what before we go any
further and i'm in favor of retaining
this bill thank you
thank you very much our representative
cordelli
thank you mr chair
i'm looking at a
document from the legislative budget
assistant dated
april 27th
and it's the estimated total education
aid
based on the house passed budget
and uh looking at
uh current law versus
what the house passed
a look at berlin
since that was mentioned
in 2022
they get an additional 355 000
uh based on the house pass budget and in
that is one of my towns there is no
change in the total aid
from moultonborough
so i think that
this information is available
many towns do receive
so i think that
is
a good document um and i'll also point
out since payroll was mentioned
um they have an increase in 2022
of 122 000 almost 123 thousand dollars
and
over 126 000
so uh
i think that most towns
looking at this document will receive um
an increase in total education paid
under the house past budget
thank you
representative
thank you very much mr chair so so you
know this is where we need to really pay
attention to to the details here
you're talking about the house pass
budget over current law which uh current
law already puts school districts in a
90 million dollar deficit compared to fy
21 the school year that's being finished
right now
so so over with current law you're
already starting out 90 million dollars
in the whole um uh representative
cordelli mentioned haverhill last so an
fy 22 i'm sorry in fy 21 haverhill
received an additional up a a a great
supplemental grant of 801.
make sure you get it right 801 514
that goes away and is being replaced by
a grant or by not a grant an increase
largely due
to the um the indexing of um of the of
the of the 3709 adequacy
to i think it's getting it gets indexed
by one and a half percent
um and so they're getting an additional
would you say represent cordelia was a
hundred thousand dollars or something
like that so it's it's it's over it's
it's about seven hundred thousand
dollars less than what haverill received
in fy 21. so this is not something that
is restoring um the house budget is not
something that's restoring communities
uh with with with resources beyond what
they re school districts with resources
beyond what they received in fy 21. it
is it is it is pushing them back
substantially
so so i think represent chairman ladd
mentioned that that over current law
again current law not fy 21 that it was
a um
a 16 million add-on so so that is still
uh 73
74 million dollars short of of of what
uh what districts received in fy 21. so
so i think it's really important that uh
that that when we when we talk about
comparing
um uh house the republican uh budget
that that we don't use this this you
know this slippery oh you know current
law um um that we that we compare it to
uh to fy21 because that's what taxpayers
are gonna do
and uh follow-up to what you just
mentioned represent luno
uh and we've discussed this a number of
times
the issue of we were provided in the
previous budget one-time money which are
amounted to 60 million
physical capacity disparity
in several several categories
that was put out by the school boards
association department of education and
other organizations
be careful with that funding you receive
it's one-time money
one-time money that should not be thrown
at labor extending labor contracts or or
getting you involved with a labor
contract that's gonna are not just a
labor contract but any kind of contract
which is going to cost you in future
years this is one-time money so that
amounted to 60 million dollars
now
i also realized that we passed a bill hb
242 which dealt with fiscal capacity
disparity eight we also indicated in
that bill there would be no
stabilization so policy has spoken out
uh unfortunately and i i agree from one
standpoint this bill is based on a lot
of stabilization
and that to me
is incorrect but that's where we are
that their districts are receiving what
they're receiving in current law in fact
more for those communities which need it
i'm not saying that the education
formula is fixed this is why we wanted
to retain and work on this from a policy
perspective
yeah i was just thinking along those
same lines
is how much of that money that you're
saying is less than
um
is because of the
uh one-time money because that can't
really be counted in what they got done
because that was a special
that was a special circumstance
but the other part is how much money are
schools getting because of coded
and that's real money as well
and does how much is that and does that
make up if you take the one-time money
and the covid money
by my calculations most schools are
actually getting more money
then they i mean you have to take out
the one-time money because that doesn't
count
but then you add in the covid money
because that's real money that they're
getting at any rate
i think uh the numbers don't work
sam porter
thank you mr chair and this is just a
comment i had the honor of
of substituting in uh the finance
committee division two when
when uh the budget was being finalized
and
a hundred million dollars
was
found or the revenue estimates came in
100 million dollars 130 million dollars
higher than had been expected and the
and the division two got a hundred
million dollars at that time to uh to
use for education and the decision was
unfortunately to use that hundred
million dollars in my opinion to give a
a one-time one-time tax cut on the um
on the property the education property
taxes as representative luna mentioned
here in hillsborough
that difference is going to get me a
nice meal um it's not going to do much
else and
that hundred thousand dollars 100
million dollars could certainly have
been used
to do what representative luna was
recommending with his amendments um so
that was one time money everything is
one-time money but we keep finding it
the next year
so i'm i'm just just pointing that out
to you we could have used that hundred
million dollars in a way that really
would have benefited
taxpayers in school districts um all
in the neediest towns in a beneficial
way instead of giving a nice
fat check to towns that have a lot of
rich property and
nice meals out to those of us who live
in property poor towns
thank you from tanner
thank you uh mr chair i just want to
point out that the coveted money had a
lot of restrictions
on it what it could be used for and also
that schools incurred a lot of costs due
to uh things that they had to do uh to
comply with kova just even routine
maintenance has now changed tremendously
because of of covet how everything has
to be disinfected um and i'd like to say
that even though it was one-time money
last year it was a way to show
that property tax relief for once could
be really really done
and done
on an equal basis and several towns that
i represent really uh need that extra
money
to help their property taxes their
property taxes are are three four times
as high as mine so
um living in a property rich town so i
think that um
you know it's time to look at
helping these schools out public schools
out in towns that are property poor and
we do that by
helping with um the extra funds that
that uh should be distributed on a
disparity basis thank you
further discussion
from
representatives
uh thank you mr chairman uh i i'm
strongly against retaining this bill
uh this is a bill that lowers property
taxes in areas that where they need to
be lowered puts
more money for education in the areas
where it's needed and it distresses me
when people on the committee say one
time money does not count
ask members of a local school board
whether the one-time money counts or not
and you'll get the answer
and i as people have said earlier i'm
glad that this particular hearing that
we're having or discussion we're having
is being
will be get into the press and we'll go
across the state and local voters will
determine
how
what happens as a result of the way we
work on this particular bill
and those will be that will be the
determination about whether
we're doing dealing with fair funding
for education or something else thank
you
further discussion representative
sure thank you mr chair
uh this committee is made up of uh folks
that have been teachers
administrators school board members
my case all three we're pretty much part
of the education establishment we care
about education we want to support
education
so i'm going to say a couple things
when
school numbers and populations go up the
argument is to give schools more money
which i think we all get in this case
the school population numbers have gone
down and yet that's being used as a
reason to give the schools more money
um and i think some of us need to get
outside the education establishment and
look at this from
from a broader perspective i just want
to read one small paragraph from a
message or letter that neil curric
former finance chair
sent to all of us and he wrote
public school districts in new hampshire
are slated to receive
350 million dollars under president
biden's 1.9 trillion american rescue
plan which is more than twice what the
federal government promised
in december's covert 19 relief packets
it's roughly eight times what schools
here were allocated in the cares act a
year ago
the so-called strings are tasked and the
use of these covert funds are tied quite
loosely according to uh neil kirk uh
they will more than cover any covert 19
related revenue losses and he finishes
is it really necessary to add state
taxpayer dollars to these already
excessively generous federal grants how
many times over should schools be paid
for covert 19 related losses so i think
that we
need to hear some of these other voices
like
thank you mr chairman
i agree with entertaining and also
comment on one time
it came supposedly with strings of tax
that should only be used for capital
improvements and infrastructure
now in our town we made sure that we had
a special meeting where we voted to put
it in our capital improvement budget so
the school board can then use it for
emergencies and that kind of stuff
you know for example
elementary school the electrical systems
probably will have to be replaced
participates way back
and other things that we know may happen
so rather than taxing
putting in the budget for a future year
today we need 50 million for this we
have money so
that's what it was supposed to be used
for it was one time for infrastructure
and capital improvement some districts
used it for other things that they
shouldn't have and now they're going to
suffer
so i think we need to retain this to
find out what if anything
the budget is going to do
also too
this as i understand it should have been
an early bill because the financial
thing but it wasn't giving it to us that
way so yeah i think we need to look at
it
look at other bills
bank with funding and come up with and
for next november come up with a good
bill to fix
some of the school funding other than
what the house does
the house
budget and the senate it
has done thank you
and i'd like to follow up to that just
for a second that
when we passed hb 242
it dealt with all the components of
adequacy
dealing with the base cost dealing with
the differentiated aid as well
uh the other areas which we've had
physical capacity disparity
above and beyond
and grant money but looking back at that
base cost
we also included within 242 the
components what make up base advocacy
what is the base cost comprised of well
it's comprised of
the teachers
support staff
books classroom uh
equipment computers technology
technology support all that has been in
that base cost for years right back to
when we all part started here and we
looked at that formula came out of that
legislative oversight committee that
dealt with all this back in 2008
we
have the responsibilities of policy
committee to look at that and to
identify
uh are the inputs now matching up with
the needs in the schools and that's
something that needs to be done we would
do that in conjunction with this
retaining the bill
and and get the policy statements
addressed
um i think that everybody agrees here
that we need physical capacity disparity
uh there's different ways of doing that
but we i thought we had all pretty much
gotten the same page in terms of using
equalized evaluation per pupil and and
trying to address those towns where
their equalized property valuations are
as low as 350 000 dollars approximately
and you have of course some that are up
for well over seven million dollars per
pupil there's a huge difference there
and a huge difference in capacity to
raise dollars but we also have other
issues we have some communities which
have
you know high property valuation per
pupil but also have
uh lower medium family incomes based
upon
the the people are living in the
community and those which are in the
condos and all that go down to
massachusetts everything actually
when the skiing season is over
and so they still have those property
valuations which they're taxing within
those committees yes but we also have
that same
value of tax save that rate applied to
those which don't have that capacity to
pay that within those communities i
understand there's problems
and i understand we need to address them
we have tried to address them and we
will continue to try to address them and
so i i just want to make it clear that
what represent also said it's something
that has to be taken into account our
demographics in the state since going
back
20 years ago are significantly lower
today than they were then and we're
expecting to see another huge decrease
in the next eight to ten years
so we cannot continue to keep funding
based upon what was received and
bullying it up for building it all up
based on our stabilization we need a
formula that's going to be accurate and
support the education needs of all in
this state and i think that that's we're
working towards that i think we have a
lot of understanding there however uh we
are hopefully the bill that we're seeing
coming through the house we did we did
uh
fund more than current law suggests in
fy 22 another 16 million dollars and
then flight 23 another 17.5 million
dollars
so there are increases there in our
course i understand represent laurels uh
where he's coming up with that data
however we're not looking at the current
law we're looking at various components
like the one-time money which is the
physical capacity which was the 60
million dollars out of that 90 million
dollars everybody's talking about thank
thank you mr chairman um
and i appreciate your comments
particularly those that reflect
been with dealing with this problem
since 2008
and the fact that it needs to be
addressed well that's the point it needs
to be addressed
um and when you're talking about
declining enrollments in the next eight
to ten years that doesn't solve the next
two years of budget and putting it back
in to way to look at this uh 242 with
the old-fashioned way account count
pencil accounts desk count kids and
divide we've done nothing to improve
education property tax relief with this
bill
i would ask how many people sitting
around this room sometime during the
last political campaign didn't say let's
reduce property taxes and let's stop
paying having state money state bills
passed on localities i can't imagine
anyone didn't say that but that's
exactly what we're doing
so we're not helping property taxes
we're not helping education uh across
the state we're supposed to be helping
education across the state for all
students
i think the fact is it passes kick in
the bucket you you are absolutely
correct representative you've been
kicking it since 2008 and then one
chance to address it we haven't
thank you
represent woodcock we've had several
chances to address it we have you look
back at the
task force report came out of 2018
and you look at what we proposed through
hb 242 we're looking at identifying the
cost of an adequate education first
what came out of the commission which
was looking at the total cost based upon
what is annually submitted by the deal
on doe 25 form
to support students which involves
athletics and all kinds of things which
are not part of adequacy so you can't
come up with an average cost based upon
everything we're spending for students
it's got to be what is necessary for
instruction and curriculum
that has not been addressed and that
needs to and that's where policy has to
step in
and that's what we're trying to do with
hb 242
representative i like this thank you
um one of the things that i am very
appreciative that representative luno
printed out that i really wanted to see
was what people are actually paying on
their taxes not tax rates not
this town is worth this much and this
town is worth this much so the first
thing i looked at was berlin
which yes has a 39.82
tax rate
but on average people pay
and 2
dollars and i looked at my town which is
considered a property rich town hudson
which is about half of what berlin is
and yet we actually end up paying five
thousand four hundred and three dollars
which is twice what the people of berlin
are paying and that's why
i
objected all
along since last term
to
planning figuring out how much
money towns should get based on their
property valuation because that doesn't
really give you a picture
of the taxes in the town
and so this gives us a better picture of
the actual taxes berlin people in berlin
are paying half
what the people in hudson are paying
even though their tax rate is twice
so and
as um representative luna said well they
make half as much money well they're
paying half as much taxes so it's still
equitable
and so i think we should we need to
spend this time to come up with
another way of figuring out like i
really like the free and reduced lunch
message if we could because we don't
have average
amount of money that people make in a
town but that makes more sense what is
the actual tax burden
to the human being to the taxpayer
not
overall and so
i think we need to go back and look at
this
thank you
so thank you very much um mr chair um
you and i and and representative miler
have obviously been and others have been
working on this a long time and i think
um and i've particularly been putting a
lot of time in on the amendments for
senate bill 135
i also put a lot of effort in
using the dra data to develop
the spreadsheets that that i sent to the
committee and sent to the media um in
the last couple of days
and and i think in all transparency when
we talk about what um what what what a
property taxpayer is paying on a median
priced home in their town we need to
have full disclosure on that which which
the spreadsheets do unlike what
representative leakas just talked about
so the median priced
residential property um in berlin is
sixty five thousand dollars um
sixty five thousand fifty dollars
actually so when they're paying almost
twenty six hundred dollars in property
tax on that sixty five thousand dollar
piece of property and um uh this comes
from the dra data uh it includes
residential land as well as residential
improved properties so that's the median
in berlin 65 000
and they're spending almost twenty six
hundred dollars in um in property taxes
on that so so um you know i think as you
go to the southern part of the state
you're going to see median property
taxes i'm sorry median property
valuations being substantially higher
than than 65 000 so i think it's
important to look at all the data in
those um
in those spreadsheets
the other the other thing that i think
is is very important to know and i think
this goes to points that were made by
representatives moffett and baum
who suggested that that look um we
shouldn't be asking the taxpayers to uh
to spend more money well first of all
the taxpayers spend money in new
hampshire on property taxes that's where
it is it's not it's not state taxes
um by and large it's property taxes for
sure when it comes to schools
and and what we're seeing in
non-property tax state revenues
going to going to schools or actually
i don't want to say going to schools um
in the uh in
in the republican house budget
is a hundred million dollars
going to um um basically going for this
like sweetheart swept tax cut
uh that that that directs those monies
to the uh to the most property wealthy
communities and then an additional 36
million dollars this would be the the 16
million in fy 22 and 17 million in fy 23
that uh that basically are are changes
in the indexed um you know amount of of
base adequacy and differential
differentiate aid it doesn't it doesn't
come anywhere close in either one of
those years
to what uh senator hennessey is
proposing in senate bill 14135
which is 45 million dollars just to
cover the basic adequacy
losses as a result of the um of the of
pandemic
enrollment shifts temporary pandemic
enrollment shifts so
so
of of that total 100 million dollars
all of it directed towards towards
towards
skewing towards the property wealthy
communities
certainly not directed at all towards
towards where the where the re-state
resources are needed most
is
is not at all consistent with i think
good government uh fiscal policy in fact
it's uh it's it's government waste
and um and what we uh what what i hope
this this
you know committee will do
is
is open the door to letting us introduce
the the three amendments that uh that
don't even total up uh at 136 million
dollars so it's actually less than what
than what you're spending right now in
in house bill 2. and uh and directs that
money to where it's needed and and just
to use you know um berlin as an example
the um
the the house budget
um
directs 34 in tax savings on that on
that median property in berlin only in
fy 23. only in fy 23
as opposed to 260
in tax savings both in fy 22 and another
260 dollars in fy 23 so over 500 in tax
savings and you see the exact same thing
in pittsfield where the the republican
budget
generates 67 in tax savings fy23 only on
the median priced home in pittsfield of
149 950
the amendments that we've got would
direct 448 dollars in in tax savings on
that same median priced home in fy22 and
that same 448 dollars again in
fy23 and it all does it
with with actually less money than than
than the then the state's currently
pushing to uh to newcastle rye
portsmouth um you know and uh and and
communities that
that have much much less need than uh
than others across the state so um
i you know i think i think
let's let's make sure when we're when if
people are saying well we shouldn't be
asking the taxpayers to do more well
first of all we're not by by uh by
adopting these amendments uh because the
the money's already in the state budget
to do this and secondly if you if you go
to retain it we are in fact asking the
taxpayers to do more and they and they
understand that they know that they'll
they'll certainly know when they see
their tax bills
thank you
tanner
thank you mr chair i not only are the
house values
different
uh and have to be taken into
consideration but not not all students
achieve
based on the same resources
and in these poor communities the
property poor communities oftentimes uh
with high free and reduced hot lunch or
they
they have a significant amount of
poverty
there's the students from those areas
take more resources
and even though the student population
is decreasing
uh in some of these areas the the need
and the cost for their education is
going up
and one of the great things about the
commission report was that it flipped us
from thinking about
how many people
how many deaths how many students we
flip that
to what does it take for student
achievement to bring everybody in their
state
up to a level of student achievement
that we will be proud of
and i'm proud that new hampshire is in
the top ten
and i'm proud to have taught at a school
that was in
the upper echelon of student achievement
but we had tremendous resources and i
can just drive 10 15 miles away from my
home
and go to another school
that's in the bottom
of the achievement bracket and it's not
because the teachers aren't trying
it's not because the school
isn't trying it's because they need
additional resources
and they have
melt their property taxes to the highest
level that that
that people just can't can't tolerate
anymore
and
it also economically affects their town
when the school is not achieving
the town doesn't
you know people don't come into the town
people come into towns because they want
a good school system for their student
for their children and
it affects businesses it expects the
real estate of that town it it affects
the the people in that town after a
while they just get beaten down
and if we can do something about it and
we can do something about it right now
and as representative luna said at
equal or even less cost but just
with some disparity um
[Music]
aid then we should do it and we should
at least look at it now
and consider it which would be
letting him put his amendments in but
even more than that let's do something
now we did something last term
that made a difference let's do
represented
yeah i
very much realized that housing
values are much higher in the south of
the state which is why i wanted this
printed up because
my point was that it's not the housing
value
that matters because my 200 year old
farmhouse is still a 200 year old
farmhouse
and its value has skyrocketed just
because i live in the southern part of
the state people want to move in which
all that says is right now there is a
small
amount of houses available and a small
number of people who make a lot of money
moving in but i will tell you while we
are well above average on property value
we are also above average on free and
reduced lunch
so just because some houses are selling
at a high amount of money which brings
the property value
up across the entire town doesn't mean
people are making more money doesn't
mean people can afford more to spend in
taxes
it just means that at the moment we have
a housing shortage in the southern part
of the state and people are willing to
pay a lot of money the people who are
moving which is a small portion of the
people who live there
are moving in and driving by housing
prices up my house value only matters if
i sell it and move in the meantime
i pay taxes based on that current value
so what i'm saying is the values are not
equal
from one part of the state to the other
a same house the same house in the
southern part of the state is going to
be valued much higher than the exact
same house in the northern part of the
state doesn't say anything about what my
income is what their income is whether
what my tax is what their taxes
and that's why i wanted to actually be
able to compare
taxes paid
rather than
what might somebody made up for the
value of my house which has skyrocketed
since i've lived in the same town all
these years but i'm not going to get any
money out of that until i move which i
may die in that house so i may never see
that increased valuation
and so my point is
property value is not the thing to be
looking at
when we're trying to figure this out
a much i mean if we could do
income
that'd be great but we don't have those
numbers but what we have is free and
reduced lunch which takes the place of
that so free and reduced lunch i think
is a much better
metric
for
how much
aid is needed for instance in nashua
same taxing same school district same
everything but as you were talking about
how students perform yes they perform
very differently from one part of that
city to another even though it's the
same school board
it's the same taxing rate it's the same
entity and yet one neighborhood does
very different than another but one of
the things you'll see different between
them is free and reduced lunch
percentages so that makes it much
because
mostly because of the amount of
attention that the students get at home
the amount of education that the
students get at home the largest
predictor in nashua of how students do
in school
is actually the education level of the
parents
and so yes we need to make up for that
but
how do you tell whether this community
and that that city or that community in
that city is going to get more or less
money
um to make up for the difference in
attention that those kids are getting at
home free and reduced lunch makes a much
better
um
metric for that and so that
i'm you know the part of this bill that
deals with free and reduced lunch on all
four it's the part that has to do with
property valuation and all of that
because i think those are artificial
numbers
um
as in
related much less to what people make
much less to what type of house and much
more to
how
desirable that and how
okay so
how few homes are available for sale and
how much valuable those homes are how
much people want to move into that area
more than anything so that's
anyway
as a committee representative like us
and i'll just reflect again back to hb
242 and i'm going to read that bill that
passed this house
and has gone to the senate there
there's a portion of that bill addressed
exactly what you just said represented
like
it says the cost of physical capacity
disparity is a separate grant from
adequacy and shall be provided to
municipalities with the lowest equalized
property valuation
that's not where you're going but it
says that it also goes on
an additional disparity achievement
proficiency increase grant shall be
provided to eligible school districts
schools and charter public schools to
improve academic achievement and growth
of level one and level two proficiency
students has identified in the annual
statewide assessment pursuant to the rsa
that level one and two there's a direct
relationship between
poverty
free and reduced
where students students on the lowest
two uh levels of that test one and two
and so we recognize towns like city
towns areas like portsmouth
have these large pools of kids which are
not achieving
that come to have a handicap of some
kind or have a disability of some kind
or that have an issue where they're not
achieving and that bill as we propose
tried to address both areas
the property valuation reputable and
those other areas which represent like
this is talking about
we have done that in our policy
statement
and here we are rehashing saying this is
what we gotta do we did it
as a policy committee we've done it
so now it's up to the whole house and
others to make sure that we get some
physical capacity security aid built in
and we don't have any more stabilization
in the future represent our syrian still
up
you're muted
i just
well
i um i think uh one of the things
representative lakers is pointing out is
how regressive property taxes are
and i hope um that she sees that and
perhaps uh
looks at maybe another way with a tax
that's probably a great reason to retain
this bill if we're looking to larger
things like changing how education is
funded or which taxes
let's retain this we have the language
we need for the pre-reduced lunch in the
budget the senate should probably keep
it since this is senator henderson's
bill i don't think that this language to
make these districts full for introduced
lunch is at risk but by retaining this
we can start looking at things because
there's a clear difference of opinion
and we're not going to hammer this out
today even if we stay tuned no we're not
going to hamper it out today and
by retaining it those bills are not dead
the bill it can be worked on and and
brought back along with 608 so
if they don't have anymore fy22
army
i just was was wondering if um the
issues that you're talking about weren't
discussed in the commission that worked
over the last year i i was under the
understanding that those kinds of issues
were what was the focus of that
commission
to keep this another year to look at
those same things that were already
looked at
through the work of that commission
seems
okay thank you very much i was a member
of that commission and of course i was
16 i was the one
it was just a matter of fact that and
we've spoken about it today there's
different
ways to put that budget together i
believe in an input
system not based upon
uh some
figure that's just extrapolated from the
uh
doe 25 form which includes uh costs
which are above and beyond what i
believe is an adequate education
and so the figures that have been used
in some cases are figures that are
higher than they should be
and are not necessarily just you know
adequacy it could be a marching band the
cost of that that is in that commission
report
uh so
but they're they're i'm not negating the
commission report and finance all the
way through there are a lot of good
things which were discussed
and uh and there's some rules i was
reflected in 242
and we we
have sent the message
uh it's now a matter of uh
i think polis has basically done our job
we can still do more work
on 608 and and
this bill itself uh 135
the the bill which we had in uh 608 we
just did not have the time because it
was an early bill
and the formula which we had the funding
formula we received
information on that almost the day that
we were taking action on it
so this committee flat ran out of time
so at this point in time
i'm going to just take a couple more
hands and then we're going to have a
vote here because we have other bills
today omnibus bills which have various
parts to them
first first of all i'd like to say this
is one of the most important bills that
we're reviewing today because it makes a
significant difference next year
um
and i would strongly recommend that we
vote down the retain
uh
motion and put an ought to pass motion
on the bill so that we can at least hear
representatives luna's amendments
and then if you folks still think or
certain folks on the committee still
think that we're you know not going to
to do this they can then
uh vote that ought to pass bill down or
motion down and we can have another
motion in its place
um but i think to to retain this bill is
to kill this bill and it certainly kills
uh hope
for many communities
many school districts and like i said
it's not just the school we're talking
about how
the property tax
and what happens at the school
affects the community and the economics
of that community so
i would i would strongly urge
that we
vote down retain
listen to the amendments and then if you
then after that if you still can't deal
with this bill
then itl or vote against the ought to
pass and put an itl up on it um to
retain it uh is just not only kicking it
down the road but it's a kick in the
face to the people that have to deal
with this next year
representative
no thank you mr chair
and i would concur with uh the words of
uh
representative tanner
earlier in this session
i requested of the of you and this
committee
to hear a full briefing
on the
school funding commission
that was tonight
in fact we had time
we've had time this month
to have that briefing
so now what we're being asked to do is
to retain a bill where we could have had
that time to really look at the school
funding i would remind this committee
to accept this commission's report
it fundamentally changes how we fairly
allocate
current school funding
not additional school funding current
school funding
to make sure that the
disparities that exist in our state
kids are not having a chance to fairly
have an equitable education as other
students
by retaining this bill
we basically are saying to those
districts that have disparities in it
no problem we don't care
for another year we're going to kick it
down the road one more year and i'm sure
we'll do it another time
totally disappointed totally
disappointed in this fundamental issue
of tax relief and funding schools that
this committee if they vote to retain
this
shirks their responsibility of making a
public statement of what we think should
be done with schools funding and tax
relief
here i'm gonna take one more hand and
then we're going to have
to retain most representation
my my question was to clarify what i
wanted to do is clarify representative
milo's statement that 16-1 vote on the
commission was straight down party lines
so i i i don't want anybody to think
that that was a bipartisan point of
order that's not yeah
that's absolutely wrong that's incorrect
that is absolutely incorrect
party lines when we met as a commission
we basically parked any political
feelings we had at the door and we were
focusing on students
there were there were more
republicans on that committee than just
representative ladd believe me that's a
totally erroneous statement including
the governor's representative on the
comments okay folks uh i i can read
about that but i'm not going to
um
i'm trying to it's just it's it's it's
officials on that committee and i went
to the chair or to represent luna and
asked could we think about putting more
republicans and elected republicans on
when the chair had the option to do so
and the answer was no
so with that i'm going to call madam
sorry
this is to retain
yes um st 135
representative cordelli
yes
representative baum
representative knotter yes
represent like
yes
representative
represent hobson
yes representative andres yes
yes
representative miller
no
representative luno
representative shaw no
representative cornell no
representative tanner
absolutely not
representative ellison
strong no
representative mullen no
representative porter
no
representative woodcock
in honor of all new hampshire students
new
nine oh representative lad
yes
eleven nine
thank you very much uh
so the uh next bill which we have to
address is
sb
44.
and i i'd like to uh call representative
for a motion please uh thank you mr
chairman i would move uh itl on house of
consciousness senate bill 44 and
representative hi zecha thank you
uh do we have uh uh anything from the
prime support maker the motion yes thank
you very much
um
[Music]
i think this will
has as many issues
many problems
it is opposed by the department of
education
department of business and economic
affairs
[Music]
email that we received from that
department and the commissioner taylor
caswell
he outlined three concerns with the bill
first of all it commits the office of
workforce opportunity
to funding a program that is not
currently part of the combined state
plan and i'll get to that in a moment
number two many of the partnerships in
the
workforce opportunity office
already have these services
and number three the community college
is free to develop any sort of trope of
training program they like
uh one year ago
all the stakeholders got together
and developed a uh combined state plan
um
i i went and found
um the plan it's over 350 pages long and
includes all the stakeholders and comes
up with a plan on how these
services
are to be provided and
who is responsible for the funding
for instance
um
rsa 282
a colon 182
dealing with the training fund
says that the funds
shall
use shall be solely determined by the
commissioner of the department of
employment security
and the commissioner shall act as fiscal
agent for all monies in that training
fund
but this
legislation
really counteracts that uh rsa without
modifying it
uh
the department of education um which has
funds in terms of adult uh education and
training um opposes it uh
so i think that uh maybe
though well-intentioned
i think that this
senate bill has many problems and should
representative
yeah exactly
yeah i agree with the ipl number one
right now
i mean people through stimulus with
money extra money
for being on unemployment
had money available to them to take the
course that they needed for a
certificate or a badge or whatever
so that money was there
there are more people look there are
more job openings
than people are that are unemployment
so
and hopefully once they
for got stopped
which is coming this next month
that
they'll see all those signs up for
everywhere just about every kind of job
opening that maybe they'll get filled
thank you very much uh discussion
representative shaw
yes thank you
we have
a problem
in our state and not just our state but
other states
young people
coming out of
quitting school
coming out of out of high school
with no direction whatsoever as to where
a workforce program like this
would
take these kids off the street
take these young people
and show them that there are jobs out
there sure you you can see in every
every uh storefront
help want it help want it
but is it something
they can do
they
so many of them don't even
understand
what it's like to work or what it is
they
i'm not expressing myself well but the
point i'm trying to make is
this is
for the betterment of the future of our
state of our cities
getting kids involved getting
young people involved
letting them realize
that
there are opportunities for good jobs
out there that they probably have no
clue that they could do
so that's my reason for supporting it
and and not supporting an ito thank you
thank you mr chairman
i uh
yeah
can you hear me all right yes you can i
i grapple with this on and off business
i'm sorry i don't always get it right um
i'd like to speak in favor of itl in
this bill
although originally i was not thinking
in that way
and the reason is the bill needs to be
improved focused and all these various
groups pull together to work in unison
rather than impartial support in various
ways what representative shaw said is
correct
but many of these students also serve uh
or are situated in situations like my
own when i was in school neither of my
parents had been to college
i had had that opportunity in their
lives and so when i went to college i
had no one at home who understood what
was supposed to happen from that
particular experience and so it takes
time to figure out where it all fits
when i taught in the community colleges
in new hampshire and in massachusetts i
had a lot of students who thought oh
i'll learn computers and i'll have to do
that i don't need to write english
essays and then i would ask him the
question how do you propose to sell your
program
if you don't write out a good
description of it and then pitch it to
somebody so they can understand it if
you can't argue it you can't sell it
and then they say oh
yeah i guess so
i worked with framing carpenters one
time and one time we were talking about
squaring the box so we could one get our
first paycheck and two get the
foundation
ready to go
and the
director of the of our our team said to
the one guy go and measure the corners
and then measure the other corners and
see if they're the same
he said why would i do that he said to
prove it that it's square so we build up
the building it'll be square
and he said
you mean there's a use for that stuff
i remember it he didn't say stuff of
course but he's a carpenter
but that's what he meant
no one had ever explained to him that
there was a use
for that stuff that knowledge
and so
he dropped out of high school
later went to a trade school but he
dropped out of school
and that's what this kind of program is
to do is to reach those
people who do not have the understanding
in their family their life experience
whatever
to get introduced to
how that will work for them to build a
career
and how to envision a life that involves
more education now you don't have to
overdo it for me and take four and five
degrees but you know a degree would be a
good start
and that's what this is
getting them to a good start to
understanding how education links with
avocation and vocation
and that's what we're really trying to
do in this kind of bill and i'm going to
work with the the people involved
and we will bring back a bill in a year
that's much better than this bill
much more focused and we'll figure in
how all the parts have to work with who
thank you very much representative
thank you uh mr chair for expediency's
sake i'll i'll direct i have two
questions and i'll direct them both to
you one
i don't remember the department of
education testifying against this bill
and i was wondering if you could just
refresh my memory on what their
objections their specific objections
were and second of all um this was this
bill was a bipartisan bill and you were
actually a co-sponsor on the original
bill
and i'm wondering if um you would mind
commenting on
what you feel
got thrown out what what part of the
baby got thrown out with the bathwater
the the bill addresses uh the
uh uh requires uh the community college
system of new hampshire
to administer this program
currently we have new hampshire
department of business and economic
affairs involved with it we also have
the department of education which is the
uh includes the career technical
education centers
uh resources come from the support of
the program they come from the
um
federal workforce opportunity investment
act
uh and that act has four titles titles
one through four
title two addresses funds for adult
education and title four vocational
rehabilitation
um
i'm concerned about how these resources
are going to be allocated now seeing the
administration of this program now is up
to the
community college system new hampshire
i'm concerned about that the longevity
of where resources are going to come
from or to maintain
this program in the future the community
system new hampshire now and university
system capture
are
in another area we're talking merger and
we don't know how the overall governance
of these uh particular groups are is
going to look like in the future
so involving the department of education
only you don't see doe mentioned in this
bill at all other than cte
and i believe that there needs to be
more reference and with involvement with
them the department is certainly a
partner
and uh
so i that
those are my concerns about this
particular bill i'm all for workforce
development and always have been and
will advocate for in the future i just
don't think you know support what
representative ford said i don't think
it's ready i think there's a lot of
loose ends in it that need some uh
better definition
i just wanted to add that um
the school board association i have here
on our notes from that hearing that they
were against
however they did not sign in on that you
know to sign up to speak or testify
right so uh brett have been looking for
that information
okay represent mylar
thank you mr chair
now is the time to do this bill i i
concur with representative ford's
comments about the need but now is the
time to do this we have people who are
getting ready to go back to work
and we have this bill provides an
opportunity for those who are going back
to work to perhaps look at another
alternative
that would advance their current
employment status beyond what they
currently or what they would have done
prior to covet now is the time to deal
with this we and also we received a
letter today from the business
the bia
they support this bill these are the
folks who are looking for
good employees they support this on the
presumption that people will have a
chance to advance themselves in the
employment center now is the time to do
this not to wait
thank you representative
cornell
i just wanted to say that i'm against
itling this we have much more support
in the hearing for the bill than against
it and like um
rep milor just said we got a letter this
morning from the bia um the auto dealers
which represents 500 businesses
supported
the community college supported it and
it said it identifies pathways for
higher skills and better jobs so there
might not be a lot of unemployment but
it's people working at
dollars and 25 cents an hour they have
to work two jobs so that's taking up a
lot of the jobs
she also said um it would position
the the group to apply for federal
grants to get more money for more
training um
the lna barriers were needed um
so i i just think that there's much more
reason to pass this bill right now than
to itl it
thank you very much representative
porter
thank you mr chair um i don't see a
fiscal note on this bill so i'm curious
as to um what money was being discussed
when you were
discussing the concern about funding
i'm talking about the administration of
the uh workforce federal monies that
come down federal workforce
communication and opportunity act the
community college would then be the
minister of that
and bea opposes it because it duplicates
existing efforts and commits agency
resources towards such efforts in ways
not previously anticipated and so plans
have been developed applications have
been received um i i just don't think
there i there's too many unanswered
questions which were brought up by the
business and economic affairs
uh folks
are the commissioner of that
organization
thank you
representative allison
uh thank you mr chair i'm just following
up on a point that representative mullen
made and i guess the question goes
either to you or representative cordelli
who at the department of education has
filed the objection to this bill was it
the commissioner or was it someone from
the office of adult education in the in
i have not talked with anyone in adult
yes
i mentioned
earlier the combined state plan
and i would encourage everyone to look
at that
the vision
that they should be the mission
that they outlined was to promote and
advocate for talent development by
partnering with businesses agencies
educational institutions and
organizations to support a unified and
an innovative workforce development
system that meets the needs of
businesses and individual customers
they outline values priorities
as i said it's over 350 pages long
they talk about
program specific requirements uh about
court programs and coordination of state
plans between these agencies
that's all in this program
there are things going on
it sets performance goals for the core
programs i would encourage
anyone who's um
concerned about this
bill and workforce development to take a
uh representative uh
tanner
thank you mr chair i i just was
wondering again the question about the
department of education's objection
i know i see that diana fenton is on uh
on this webinar and i was wondering if
perhaps she could tell us what their
objection is thank you she's here we can
yep she's here okay
miss fenton we're going to promote you
just
welcome to education
thank you good morning
i believe the
question um i don't i don't recall
testifying on this bill i might have uh
so forgive me at this point in the
session uh sometimes my memory fails me
um i do recall um
that
the concern
was simply the it appeared to be a very
limited role the deal we would play in
this bill um and
that to the best of my knowledge was the
only concern and but again i don't
recall if if i testified to it and i
don't believe that anyone from adult
education uh to address rep uh
representative ellison's
question um
thank you
are there any questions of uh
representatives
attorney
um
uh
mr chair thank you not overtraining
fenton just when you have a moral thank
you
okay thank you very much uh
diana
um
thank you mr chair i just i'm going back
to the presentations and looking at my
notes and i kept on
recalling reflect on my notes that this
bill's focus was unemployed and
underemployed
um and i agree with representative shaw
that this is in milo this is the chance
to move forward for folks that need to
get out of the 7.25
uh range and get some skills and you
have businesses including the auto
industry they came up and spoke yes yes
yes we need people who are helping to
train them i i think what we're doing a
disservice to our young people of the
state i know a lot of this bill to go
through
uh thank you representative
representative luno
thank you very much um mr chair um i
guess i'm looking at my notes i'm trying
to understand where the doe objection
came from just as i think many people
are i just scanned email i didn't see a
letter
i was wondering if if i mean looking at
my notes i don't see anybody from the
from the department testifying so um i'm
just wondering where that where that
came from and i think um representative
cordelia i think you
yes i i
i recall some conversations with people
um uh i i don't have my notes with me on
that
um but i would just like to say that uh
the department of education in the
uh wioa combined state plan
is one of the required partners both in
terms of titles one two and four
uh
so
they are a significant partner
with
the others
in that state plan
representative ellison
uh thank you thank you mr chair for
taking my question uh based on your
answer uh
recent answer
is it now the fact that we do not have a
written objection from the department of
given where we are now do we have a
education to this piece of legislation
um i don't recall seeing an email
from them
um well so
sure mr chair so would it would then be
fair to say
that that um that the department has not
weighed in on this legislation as
opposed to what was um what was offered
earlier i
i don't know of an official position
that they have taken uh
um
representative uh
leah just stepped out for a moment to
take a call
uh i see uh representative boehm has his
hand up
in the past
automobile associates dia
and other industries has worked with the
community college to develop
training
examples
my own past experiences
the company would do that training
don't need
government spending
general government spending in this case
to do that
already so
we do not need this program there are
courses available i do agree
that high schools are not teaching what
they should be teaching
for example even when i went to high
school many decades ago
i mean i said what would i need this
basketball to teach you well because in
most cases the teachers have never been
out of the classroom
and that's one of the problems and that
was brought up on how to figure out the
right angle and why what to use it for
measuring the decks and those kind of
things i mean i didn't know that until
afterwards
uh you know watching it
but
the thing is training is available for
high school i'm not doing a good job on
it i'm not telling people
why this is needed why you shouldn't do
this but
this is not part of that and industries
thank you mr chair um i visited a
similar workforce development uh group
over in vermont
and you know the big thing uh just like
uh representative ford said a lot of the
soft skills like just you know going to
work getting up
uh how to dress for work how to talk to
people how to shake hands how to look
people in the eye
those kinds of things
uh
a lot of students a lot of kids uh and i
think representative shaw mentioned this
a lot of kids that are just they don't
have direction they don't have direction
at home
um you know this is this is something
that takes them from that level
uh and gives them
that type of mentoring
that
you know
yes teachers teach
things like that that's why we have
performance-based uh assessments now um
and experiential learning that's being
taught in schools but if it's not at the
home if it's not in their culture if
it's not uh something that that rings a
bell in their head
that sometimes they're not ready for it
but certainly once they get out in the
real world and they they want to get
into the workforce well they don't
necessarily want to get in the workforce
but they need a job they need to get in
the workforce we need them to get into
the workforce and get off the streets
this is this is a great opportunity and
um i i personally don't see
such a bad objection to this
that
we can't pass it
and then people work on it that are part
of this uh group that that's been listed
in here i think the community colleges
are
well suited uh to take this on
and um i would i would oppose the itl um
i think uh
from representative ford's point of view
a retain
um to work on it and bring it back uh
also would be good but itl is just i
think it's to kill this bill right now
sends out a bad message again it's a
message as well as an opportunity so i
thank you very much um
cordelia do you have a hand up yes thank
i uh again go back to the fact
that we have a state plan
that's been in effect for uh
i think a little bit less than a year
we've heard before about giving programs
the chance to work
well
we have a state plan that all the
stakeholders were invested in
and contributed to
anywhere from the
employment security to the department of
education
senior community service employment
program
they're all involved in developing this
state plan
i would hope that anyone who is going to
vote
against the itl would have looked at the
state plan and know what is going on
what happens to the funding that's
elsewhere in statute
what happens what happens there the job
training fund what happens to that it's
under the department of employment
security do we just ignore that rsa
this i'll point out uh
this takes effect on passage
so
we're headed for a lot of problems
if we pass this bill
okay at this point in time i'm gonna
it's uh attorney fenton's still there
these are these are the questions that i
had as well
that the we have a state plan
and we're going to change something
without having
gone through the application process for
the feds and put this in effect
immediately upon being passed
uh that there's something that doesn't
equate there with me i'm not against
workforce support but i'm uh this
process seems that needs more work
tony fenton there yes
she's able to speak go ahead
yes thank you good morning um
so in looking at this language
representative ladd um
i do agree if you look at page two
lines two and three um it says use
resources from the federal workforce
opportunity investment act
um so i just had the opportunity to
speak with the commissioner and that is
a concern because it would use resources
from a federal program and we believe
that would violate
our obligations
under this federal program in terms of
how we disseminate those funds
and the effective date is a concern as
well
so uh attorney pat the question then
when we're looking at modifying how we
use these funds from federal programs
and we have all kinds of federal
programs what's the process for
realigning how we use uh can you explain
the application process a little bit or
i can speak to it in general terms
without going into the details of this
particular grant um you know we would
have to look at
the
the requirements and obligations of that
particular federal program and see how
they can be uh allocated and see if
there's any
opportunity for a waiver
okay
so
are there other questions that may be
directed to department of education that
attorney
yeah i just wanted to make sure i
understand
um
if we pass this and this sounded really
good to begin with but if we pass this
are we then violating other rsas that
are already in existence
regarding
monies for this very
type of program
or federal law either one
so the concern again if you look at line
three on page two of fall
is that term
use resources from federal workforce
opportunity investment acts and so the
can you know the concern is that this
would violate
um
the federal program yes
that's right
the federal program or the federal
application for
how we use those monies okay thank you
very much
diana
represent milo you have your hand up for
our questions yes i do
mr chair i just
we can't forget i think the essence of
what this bill is about
and let me quote from the bill
the purpose of the workforce pathway
program
is to advance the skills
and placement of unemployed
underemployed new hampshire adults into
high demand job entry positions by
providing job-ready credentials through
a certificate program further it says
that the program shall provide training
to furloughed laid off dislocated
underserved and other populations
affected by covet
so this is an immediate issue
and i don't see
why this is a problem particularly when
you have businesses
who are saying they need this program
now
why would we want to itl this
thank you
i think one of the concerns uh
representative milo is that
and taylor
caswell in his letter whose commissioner
of the dea
stated as his number one concern about
this bill
it commits owo to funding a program that
is not currently part of the combined
state plan
so we have a state plan that's been
approved federally
and now we're going to change it can't
we use those resources i don't believe
we can use those resources
i think the bill
probably needs uh and i agree i like the
idea of the workforce and the whole
principle behind this but i'm concerned
and that's why i signed on to it as a
sponsor of the bill initially
when i didn't see this part or
understand this part now seeing how it
interacts with federal dollars and the
application has been approved by the
feds
but we're going to change it without
that approval on the feds
that's that's where it breaks down for
myself
president porter
thank you mr chair i have
two parts two questions first of all um
is that something that could be fixed
with an amendment to this bill
because it is important bill and if
that's the sticking point perhaps a way
around it could be worked
my second um statement is i wanted to
respond to something that representative
foam had mentioned earlier on about
schools not preparing
young people for the trades
and i just wanted to make a comment that
yesterday i was on a zoom call where a
superintendent of a property poor town
was promoting the fact that he had no
had to eliminate the elementary school
art teacher position because they
couldn't afford to fund it
and in my own school district i know we
have not had
on campus
a manual arts or home economics or those
kinds of trade
courses
because we could not afford to keep them
any longer
and those are the kinds of skills it
seems to me that some of the that this
bill is aimed at and if the local public
schools can't afford to keep that
those kinds of programs running in their
districts then this kind of a program is
exactly what some people might need to
get those skills so i i really wish
there was some way that you this
committee could figure out how to fix
this bill so we could move it forward
for the benefit of people who just like
a representative milo red who this bill
is geared towards
thank you
yes as you bring up a couple good points
there represent porter one of the
concerns another concern that i had
after thinking about this is that it
gives authority for administering this
program to the community college system
in new hampshire
they're now going to be administering a
program that impacts high school kids
and career technical education there's
no mention of how doe is involved with
that in in
uh
working cooperatively with the
community college system that's not
mentioned in this bill whatsoever
thank you mr chair it's interesting that
you bring that up because i i was again
when i was doing the substituting in the
finance committee one of the programs
that the department of education wanted
to drop was i think they call it the
running start program which is where
high school students get credit for
community college courses that they
would take um and the community colleges
were eager to take that on and took on
that responsibility because they felt it
was an important thing so i i'm seeing
that the community colleges
most likely would be
perfectly fine with administering this
program
given what they said what the testimony
was that they said during the finance
committee
further
representative cornelia i'll just point
out that
there is a state workforce innovation
board swib
that improves all these players
the board
they came up with this state plan
um
would
this board
workforce innovation be supplanted by
and that that that goes to number two in
uh concerns
where he says many of our partnerships
we have in owo and on the statewide
board
already provide these services a more
effective method of addressing workforce
gaps would be to evaluate existing
programs and see if there are other ways
to integrate them with existing and
represent us
well i guess i was following up the
question
is there an amendment is this just
violate too many of our our of our
the only other way i involve doing
something because there are some issues
that are real serious issues is to
either one retain it
or
or um
or change the bill into a study
committee and i don't want to do that
because we have a board to do that
so the only other option i would think
would be to retain it
and and get the statewide board that's
responsible for all these partnerships
together
and see where they're coming out so then
we could make a recommendation uh
following the summer when we come back
again
uh this bill will be taken up and with
recommendations and with mending
language we might be able to do
something but not oppositional to
retaining that i'm not oppositionally so
would it make more sense to retain it or
to just start from scratch and come up
i think there are many issues including
wiser to itl this people can look at all
those issues over the summer talk to the
state board
talk to other players in the process
and
see if there is a reasonable
piece of legislation that could be
introduced next year
we apparently have two departments that
are absolutely bea and the department of
education has questions as well
so i would say there's two commissioners
there that have concerns i don't think
they're saying we're against workforce
development that's not what they're
saying they're just saying we have a
statewide plan and we've got that
combined plan we've got to work within
the limits of that plan
and this bill seems to be jumping ahead
of the plan and
utilizing resources in a way that had
not been approved by the vets earlier
so
i i i tend to agree with representative
also that there are a lot of issues here
and
but it doesn't negate that the statewide
you know
combined state plan group to to look at
this
they don't need to be directed by us to
yeah it was a follow-on to what you said
um
it occurs to me that if we ipl this we
may not be able to come up with
a bill that does the same thing next
year
that if we retain it we can so should we
not be paying yeah
that's correct if you if you itl bill
you cannot bring up a similar bill in
the same
biennium so does it make no sense to
retain it
i
follow up to my previous comment i i
don't see that it would be uh
necessarily a similar bill i think that
there are so many issues that it's going
to be a much different program that what
we have before us now
i just want to make sure we're not
limiting yourself that's all conjecture
too from everybody here we don't know
what would happen right
because i i hate to lose what we're
trying to do
but this isn't the way to do it
but how do we
do it i guess
well you know when something comes to us
where there's some significant problems
especially when you're down to the 11th
hour on the 11th day 11th month here
um it's it's um
can't be done
you you've got either you know if it's
i would say there's some issues there
that are
really deep wide-ranging issues
that i don't think that by retaining
what
yes um
i see this bill as
an implementation a
a way to get things rolling
uh gets things starting and in a
centralized way
versus the silo way that's been talked
about with the
um
different commissions on workforce
development you know we do a little here
a little there a little there and as
representative milor said this is the
time
we're we're in a very special special
situation that we haven't ever been in
before with this pandemic
and we have
a workforce issue problem
uh it's very apparent we hear it in the
news every day
and i think
i don't personally see
how
this bill could not be amended
um or changed so that we could keep this
uh this idea rolling i think
representative ford wants to keep it
rolling but as representative lake has
pointed out if it's similar bill
um there's always the possibility that
it can't be introduced next term and by
then
you know who knows what the economic
situation is going to be
so um i would definitely say
that we should either amend this or
retain it but definitely not to itl it
again
i'm still trying to work all of this out
because i very much as i said liked the
idea and like the idea of this i know
there's a need
on the other hand if we pass something
that violates our own
laws it's not going to work and so
clearly we can't pass this
as it is because it violates our own
laws and so the question is just what is
the best way to move forward
the question is what are our own laws
and as long as we can put in that new
bill
which um
representative ford was talking about
doing
is there a way can we ask the clerk or
something
i know we have the answers right here
we can either
retain the bill
and you can do something you can pull
people together and okay how can we move
in this direction but you can't move in
that direction until you've got it
approved by the feds
if you're going to use federal dollars
so do we have somebody from the fed who
can
well i know
acceptance from the feds to modify the
plan that we have
our waiver yeah and i i i'm not an
administrator over at doe or at uh
at the bea
and i don't know that process well
enough
so um
i guess at this point in time
um i like to call a caucus amongst
republicans here to discuss this
um
15 or 20 minutes
and and uh uh try to resolve this so
this afternoon after lunch we can do the
7148 thing
uh and try to get this thing resolved
right now if we can't before lunch
so we'll call it caucus here it's by the
clock on the wall here
the computer clock says 124.
okay so you want to say 11 45
yeah let's let's come back at 11 45 or
let's give it a little bit longer than
that about another five minutes we'll
come back at 11 uh 50
and and uh and we will be cognizing at
the same time
okay thank you
thank you arthur
thank you
for picking up the sphere of who is it
about
that's where that is
so
talk for a few minutes
representatives
march
yeah i am rick uh
so i'm talking
go ahead
so uh what
what we would be prepared to do is
that if uh
if the itl could be defeated we would
support the retention of this
so that
the respective parties could get
together and try to work on something
that could bring it back uh next session
so what we're going to do now that i'd
like to do it quickly if we could i'm
going to ask the maker the motion to
okay
so
um
that that's where we're coming
down on it uh
we like the idea workforce we really
think it's important but we there's some
we got to work with the commissioners
from these various organizations all the
partners and getting that plan to make
sure the plan we're not screwing it up
with the keynote
so
okay that's good and that's that's kind
of what oliver was talking about too so
uh so let's just move that way and we'll
we'll we'll then okay so when we open it
up here in a few minutes that's what
we'll do well okay thank you you're
welcome
um
i was wondering if you knew what
happened to dave danielson i was shocked
to read that
um
i i do uh
he
has been
placed into at-home hospice
he uh has been seriously ill for the
past six months or so
oh
yeah it's just
heartbreaking to our community he is a
well-loved community member and
representative and
bad doesn't even begin to describe it
exactly well i
i
uh
have been
you know
uh
not friends but
uh have had many conversations with them
and everything and i i found him always
to be a gentleman and congenial and he
always goes out of his way to say hi
um i think he's a great legislator
i think it's so sad i really do
he uh no he he
is a man among men i'll tell you that
and
really one of the first people that
encouraged me to run
so
uh honestly in looking at
true and fair representation of a
community he encouraged me to run and um
gave me great advice over make a new one
okay are we back yet yes we're back
we're back live yep uh rep show can you
hear us
yeah okay okay fine
um so uh i spoke with uh representative
miller a few moments ago
and um for the
for all to know what we're going to be
doing here i'm going to ask
the maker of the motion to
pull back his motion of itl
and the second as well
and then
we're going to have a motion brought
forward
by all of our board
representative ford to retain the bill
so we can work
so
representative ford as you mentioned
like the bill he likes the idea
workforce and all that won't speak for
them but there are these issues that
we've been discussing
that are our administrative issues and
management issues etc etc
so um would that represent cordelia i
believe you were the maker of the motion
would you please consider re uh pulling
it back uh yes i was and uh i will
withdraw my ipo
and what about the second
one yes
he does it reluctantly but he said yes
okay so representative ford would you
please make a motion please
can you hear me now yes we can sir uh
thank you mr chairman uh
i move at this point we've retained this
uh bill is there a second i'd second
that motion that's represent a mile a
second that motion notion made by
represent ford second by represent miler
to retain sb 44.
let's go ahead and have the vote so we
can get a little luncheon okay
um
would you
would you call the role please uh madam
clerk
yes this is to retain sb 44.
representative cordelli
yes
representative
representative notter
yes
representative
yes representative hobson yes
representative andrus yes representative
ford
yes representative leon
yes
representative soti
representative miller
yes
representative luno yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison
yes representative mullen
yes representative porter yes
representative woodcock yes
representative ladd yes
20-0
the good discussion we had folks
um let's hope we can do something with
that uh we will be putting together a
subcommittee to work on that uh and i'm
gonna do that immediately i'm also
looking at some once we finish today all
our bills will get these subcommittees
going
and hopefully we can
move forward
put some positive answers here for all
this stuff
thank you very much rick i've got a
question uh as we go forward with the
next two sets of ominous spills
is it your intent
to take these amendments uh up by number
or how are
how are you planning on dealing with
these amendments
um
part uh are
of course it's all going to come up by
parks
and
we can
take the amendments
i i really haven't given that any
consideration as far as you know
um
how which one to dress first how many do
we have in some of those parts you know
i know we're going to take all these
parts up separately yeah get an
amendment for each one
go through and then amend the entire
bill with the amendments that we
approved to be combined into one
amendment
that's no ls thing
so i did i i just think on a couple of
those bills you have
multiple amendments for parts and i just
didn't know how
what the i
it's frankly to help me get organized
is what i'm trying to do here
i'm still trying to get organized for
usb 44. no
uh no i i what we're going to do is
we're just
i would put all your your amendments for
each part for 147 there
and we'll be looking uh we'll be looking
at all those amendments
um
for each part and going through it like
that that's basically all i can say
right now okay fine
you're welcome
so let's take a break for lunch here
it's uh close to 12 o'clock
um
how long does folks need someone
we got to go out
yeah they all got to go out to eat here
there's no place to there's not a
45 minutes can you do it 45 minutes guys
gals where did you get them
where do i pick up
if you
can make in 45 minutes it'd be
appreciated if you get hung up by a slow
waiter or waitress
so we're going to start at 12 45 okay
rick what room are you guys in i need my
record
yeah
tell everybody tonight
well thank you let's just take that 45
minute break
oh
that's an old joke when the rice cake
first came out from people on diet hey
if you put cheese on it
taking a job as a special assistant to
wow
something
satisfaction
uh
so they calculate their
protein portions down to the last one to
and i'm sure they don't put an ounce
your
get rid of that bug you've got
this happened
you know something there are lot of tips
and there are people and they're looking
[Music]
foreign
okay
you
oh
um
okay
want to give it a test and see can you
hear us out there
yes
okay good
okay we're ready to go ahead with the
uh
147 and 148 we'll take 147
first and there's four parts this bill
so we'll go through and
identify what we're going to do with
each particular part
and then at the conclusion of dealing
with the
action wherever it goes in part four
then we'll take action on the total bill
with those amendments which we've made
there'll only be one amendment that
we're going to have for
each party
so part one
is um the let me get that bill out here
[Music]
relative relative to filing an
application for federal student aid
and i'll hand the gavel over to
represent gordelli so i can make a
motion
thank you mr chairman and i will call
upon uh
chairman for a uh motion
thank you very much representally uh in
regard to part one i offer
uh i octopass with amendment
1537h
and uh
you want to pass the camel back i will
yes i would suggest
so you pass the gallon back to me and i
would be glad to make a second traffic
okay so we have a motion made by lad and
second by cordelli
for
uh
it's an hmm dealing with relative to
filing an application for federal
student aid
mr chair
yes
can someone email me that amendment i do
okay um
i can send that out represent glad yeah
thank you all these amendments that i'm
i'm i'm dealing with we're all sent out
to the full committee uh if you're a
substitute you probably don't have that
that's right i have the others but i
don't have this one
yeah okay thank you
okay what i've done with this amendment
rather than taking a lot of time i took
section one deleted that section two
deleted that
and added underneath the delivery of
inadequate education
uh simply put um
after sub graph paragraph 10 the
following new sub uh paragraph will
appear there for the delivery of an
adequate education
and it states the number and percentage
of graduating high school students
provided in-person school assistance in
completing a free application for
federal student aid
parentheses fafsa form
um i
i'd like to go ahead and explain that
i understand that the
need for students being aware of fafsa
and and
to be
offered help
through somebody within the school
to
provide them uh information and how to
file and not file but how to fill out
that
application i do not
have not incorporated in the number and
percentage of graduating high school
students filing on that patient because
that is information sometimes
very personal appearance and they file
that without the school knowing that
and i believe it's what we need to know
as a school
is in support of what i
have here in a magazine called next
education
this is a a journal provided to the
education committee
and
i'm going to read just a small part of
what a high-touch nudge would be in
terms of helping kids with fafsa
graduating seniors were provided and
this is in a a situation where they
tried to
find out one of the best ways of
supporting kids with fafsa
graduating students were providing
in-person assistance over three
workshops to help choose a program they
would likely get into applied to that
program and applied for financial aid
college enrollment increased by five
percent
percentage points overall and by nine
percentage points among those not
enrolled in university track courses
so there is some benefit to our working
with kids
the last part i'd like to read
they're very short a high-touch nudge
for example and helping kids apply to
college and understanding the fafsa
it is perhaps not surprising that
person-to-person interactions are more
persuasive compared to text messages
email or mail
interventions using real people
offering up-close help such as
application assistance coaching or
tutoring show more consistent positive
impacts than low-touch cut
touch cut not just for doing the the
fafsa such as
just providing it to the kids and saying
go you fill it out or sending it home
and
by way of the kid to the parents to say
parents donut parents have had a lot of
difficulty in filling out the fafsa and
in order to
be accepted for pell grant money you
need to fill the fafsa
and so it's my feeling here where we put
down the
indicators of uh what we're doing in
support of delivering an adequate
education we'd add one underneath all
the others which talk about the number
of
kids graduating the number of kids etc
going on to the military and it lists a
whole list of things which indicate
whether we are doing our job as an
education body
uh this one right here just asked for
the number percentage of graduating high
school students provided
in-person school assistance
now i've gotten a spreadsheet here from
various school districts within our
state and it varies widely
widely there are some school districts
that have less than 20 percent of their
kids that are graduating filling out the
fafsa
there are other districts which is more
the norm or the middle of somewhere
around 39
to 40 45
but then we have some districts which
are
really doing a great job in it
uh for example lincoln woodstock 60 to
64 percent fill it out
extra 60 64
portsmouth 60 64 percent bow school
district 60 64
colebrook the same hollis brookline
70 to 74
profile up above franconia
um 70 to 74
and the virtual learning academy charter
school 75 to 79 percent
gets 70 to 74 i just jumped around son
of peace 70 to 74
but there's many that are down in the
30s the question is why
and but we this stuff comes to us from
the
national clearinghouse
not from the state of new hampshire
so i believe that this is important but
we don't need all the other stuff on top
of this i believe we should enter in
where it's required for
kids to be
in person
work with at school or in a work session
with parents after school like one of
the school districts does with three
separate work sessions
very very helpful so i think this should
help it also help us help those school
districts which are not doing this
and to be aware so we can encourage
everybody to have that opportunity to
complete the fafsa and get support if
there are disadvantaged to go to um
college or university
should be noted that this filling out
the fafsa is most beneficial to kids who
come from poverty situations
further discussion uh uh represent
porter
thank you mr chair it kind of struck me
when you were reading those um the lists
of um
school districts where there was a high
percentage of applicants
filling out the the fafsa seem to be
have
a population that's highly educated or
has a high proportion of college
educated parents
that may be
encouraging and aware of the process
more so than perhaps in my district
and also seem to be the schools that are
well funded
and
possibly have available
the manpower to meet
with the students more frequently
than others districts do so would be
interesting to find those statistics as
well
the number of guidance counselors per
student for example or
the socioeconomic
status of the families might be
interesting too so i would think that
keeping this requirement in the bill
would help the communities that are
having that aren't aren't so gifted to
be aware and to work with their students
if it's a requirement
um might help them
just seems to me
thank you
fancy i've seen ants
thank you very much mr chair yeah so i
think you know i think your comments
relative to um
students and and families uh receiving
some uh assistance
in terms of helping them complete the
fafsa is is right on and i think part
one of the bill as presented includes um
uh that uh that type of assistance from
the local school district
um i i
you know i picked up on the same thing
when you were listing off the towns like
we've been sort of doing all day
um that that representative porter uh
picked up on that uh that that these are
towns across the state that um
that um
aren't necessarily representative of um
of of all of our school districts
uh in the state
and that um that at least data
through uh
in new hampshire through um through at
least the beginning part of the year
showed that only about um 36 percent of
high school seniors had had completed
the fafsa
uh for this year the year that they're
graduating and i know obviously there's
more time in the year and
and uh but for a lot of these seniors
you know we're we're um we're
you know past decision date as far as as
far as going on to higher education
and uh getting an early jump start on on
the fafsa getting assistance from from
the school district
and um and letting students know you
know
particularly if it's dispelling
um you know some sort of preconceived
you know notion that no our family can't
afford
uh to go to higher education and go on
to higher education and love to do it
but we just can't afford to do it
um you know having uh having a fafsa
requirement
more importantly having having the
district
you know provide some support there and
certainly encouragement certainly a
graduation requirement provides some
encouragement yes there's a waiver uh to
it so i don't think it disenfranchises
anybody but um
but you know what um you know what's
been seen in other states
uh like um uh like louisiana and i think
the question came up
you know the other week you know what's
uh what's been the success uh there
and in louisiana they saw um
fafsa completion go from go from 57
to 77
and uh and that's pretty significant i
think that's consistent with um
with with at least new hampshire's um
goals for um higher education attainment
not talking four-year colleges not
necessarily even talking a two-year
associate's degree but um but high-value
certificates things that really help to
um
uh improve
uh uh and make an educated um
workforce available to our um for our
economy so
i
don't support the amendment but do
support
as it's laid out in
part one of 147.
thank you mr chair just uh clarify two
clarifications um if you if you will the
first one is
so all of part one is going to accept
this one amendment is that correct
abstract
okay and part two of my question is when
you're identifying in-person school
assistance for the
does group meetings count i know a lot
of high schools do group two three night
group meetings does that suffice to
counters in person are you looking
actually to try to ascertain how many
one-on-one with guidance counselors
i would say that in-school uh group
meetings after school group meetings
count
okay
and the students in after school as the
nhata act
um
that does that and i remember a dozen
years ago my granddaughter was working
going to college i came and it was a
couple
meetings exactly what you're doing
and that do this
even go as far as
doing the fafsa
applying for grants applying to
different colleges
so their organization there's an
organization
goes around to the high school i think
they just have to be invited and they'll
additional language i think it just
opens up the door
because what happens then is what
let the students and the
families decide what they want the kids
yes i do mr chair and
i i'm concerned one of it seems to me
one of the focuses of this bill is to
help open up the eyes of students who
may
not be aware that they yes indeed could
go on to a further education that that
the cost of it might not be
as prohibitive for them as they thought
it was that
if they even had an inkling in the back
of their mind that they might want to go
on to further education but they've
heard how expensive it is they don't
even try
and
to to to pursue it and i know a couple
of very bright young people that that
happened to over the years
and it seems to me that the purpose of
this making it a requirement or signing
a waiver is to keep is to open those
children and their families eyes to the
possibility that yes further education
is possible for them
and i think that's one of the reasons
why we're looking for 75 percent
completion rate of the fafsa because it
means that all those kids are now
realizing that yeah they can they can
maybe go on to school afterwards if they
want and by just putting it in as a as a
statistic
under
whether schools are providing an
it seems to not
meet that need number one and number two
it seems as if that
requirement is set up to shame schools
in a certain in a certain way well you
know if you don't if only 25 of your
kids are filling out fastest you mustn't
be doing a good job
and and i just
i disagree with that i think there are
many reasons why kids won't be filling
them out not necessarily that the school
hasn't hasn't tried
those traveling programs that go around
to the schools they're very good but the
parents have to be motivated to get the
kids there
or or the kids have to be motivated to
get themselves there
and that's defeating the purpose too of
opening some eyes so i really would
not be supportive of of the amendment
and would tend to agree that section
part one should stay in the bill
thank you
further discussion
represent cordelia thank you mr chairman
uh i support uh this amendment i cannot
support the language in
in the
original bill
we just heard from a representative that
parents have to be motivated
well here in the original bill
what motivation is there in order to get
a high school diploma you have to fill
so
requiring
the parent to fill out waivers is not
much of a motivation factor what if the
parent says i'm not going to fill out
this waiver you know we have problems
getting information from parents so many
times already um what happens if the
parent doesn't feel out of weight
you know are they not uh not graduate
the student
um so i
i think uh without this amendment uh
part one is an unworkable and uh example
of government overreach
further
comments represent uh
andres
thank you mr speaker
the original
part one i am against but i
support this amendment
because we shouldn't be mandating any
more
but
parents and their students need to do in
order for a person to graduate
also in this day and age i know my
school district and i imagine it's in
most school districts
emails go out to parents all the time on
all different subjects and everything
and there's no reason
information
on this can be sent to the seniors and
their parents in the high school and i
think it should take care of the whole
students make up the decisions that they
want to do thank you
you're welcome
mullen excuses
all right it's because we look so much
just a couple of things to
representative cordelli's concern about
um
kids not graduating if their parents
won't sign the waiver there is a
provision in the bill that says that if
the student is faced with extenuating
circumstances
but have met all of the other graduation
requirements then they would not
not graduate as a result of this so
that's one thing and the second thing
that um the question that i actually
have representative ladd is for you
in looking at the amendment i understand
the necessity to collect the data
because we don't know where we are
unless we
you know get some numbers from people
but i don't understand um what your
vision of the mechanism for delivery of
services is
so how
would
schools
feel compelled
and how would parents feel compelled to
work as a team to get it done
what what is your vision of that
i think that that's a local issue
in person uh is
for the school district to determine or
the high school to determine uh just as
long and as the student has an
opportunity
to meet in person or even in a group uh
where they work through this form but
for us to prescribe a certain format uh
for every school to follow i don't think
that's going to be
workable given the real differences in
how we structure and organize our
schools
further
comments represent cordelia
just in relation to
the current bill and uh
extenuating circumstances
so that means that if the parent does
not fill out
the waiver
uh
that that would be an extenuating
circumstance and the child could still
graduate so what is the purpose of
having the requirement for a waiver in
i i i i am are you directing that to me
representing
anybody to anybody
i'll take a stab at it even though i was
not involved in the in the authorship of
the bill
it provides different kinds of
information i mean filling out the the
fafsa says we want to see whether or not
we qualify
filling out the waiver says we were
given the opportunity
but have chosen not to take it
for whatever the reason happens to be
whether it's because of privacy or
because somebody doesn't think they're
gonna meet the economic requirements or
um but it also says that local schools
would determine the extenuating
circumstances so
if your
parents were either for incapacitated or
unable or unwilling to participate
then i think that
that's an ex that is the prime example
of when a local decision needs to be
made by the people that know the
children and the family and can uh you
know
determine that something's extenuating
thank you
further discussion on the amendment
not seeing any uh
madam clerk will you call the roll on
amendment
she there
can't hear you barbara
you did bob i i thought you were
unmuting us
okay um
representative cordelli
yes
representative bone yes
representative
uh representative uh daughter
yes
representative lycus
represent moppet
yes
representative hobson yes
representative andrus
yes
yes i'm sorry
representative leon
yes
representative soti yes
representative milor
no
representative luno
representative shaw no representative
cornell no
representative tanner no
president ellison
no
representative mullen
representative uh porter
no
representative lad
yes
okay are there any other amendments
for this section
i don't think i have any here
hold on you've you've got one wreck
i do
yeah am i missing this
no
1558.
i went through that amendment um
i'm not presenting it
okay thank you you're welcome
not seeing or hearing any good ronda
part
three
and i will recognize uh alicia uh like
us for a
motion please
i would um like to move otp
okay for everybody we have a motion for
part three
uh uh emotions made by
uh alicia leicester and second by dem uh
thompson this uh
part three is relative to the
transportation pupils and contract
carriers so everybody can remember what
we're talking about
you know the
the trailways the greyhounds the concord
bus that type of thing
could you please explain uh the
amendment um
yes um
representative
woodcock and i spent a fair amount of
time over the weekend in the beginning
of this week
doing a lot of research i know i talked
to a number of different bus companies
principals of schools
people who plan
the dc trips
and we've both read
all of the rsas concerning contract
carriers and
the
ones mentioned in this part
and we could not figure out even if we
stood on our head and crossed our eyes
how
uh part three
section three of part three
could possibly apply to contract carrier
drivers
because it has to do with schools
and
anyway the the
the rsas
if you did crazy convoluted wording and
stuff which this doesn't do you might be
able to figure out how to make it apply
but it really doesn't and it really
doesn't work
and so
um
what this amendment does is it takes out
that
section three
and the um school bus driver certificate
to find an rsa 263 29 which is in both
section one and section three
um after
after um
rep woodcock and i
talked about all of this i actually
managed to get callbacks from
other bus companies that i had managed
to talk to earlier had a nice long
conversation with the vice president of
new england coach
and answering a number of the questions
and concerns that we had
[Music]
one thing i asked was would they ever
take
students without adult chaperones and
she just
just about lost into that question she
said
nobody who values their business at all
would ever take the risk of transporting
students
without
proper adult chaperones that it wasn't
worth the liability and the risk to
their company to do that so nobody would
do that
number two safety instructions one of
the things that we were both concerned
about was
um how do the kids know how to use the
emergency exits etc
and i know when i talk to
a principal they said they always sat
the adults in those exit
next to those exit windows rather than
coach
company she said that these days coach
they're so
modernized that basically the drivers
push a button and a little
thing comes up on the video that
explains things like where the
the fire extinguishers and how do the
emergency exits work where are they out
located and whatever just like we do on
airplane
and so it's all automated and easy and
they just push a button and boom there
it goes
um and she said all of the reputable
companies that she knows operating in
our state do that
so there's something they're already
taken care of
she also said that
coaches and one of the things that i was
discovering and doing
research on this
is extremely highly regulated federally
so a lot of the things we were looking
at having done
it's like that's federal regulations
already you know they they there are so
many hoops they have to jump through
just even exist
that it takes care a number of things
i asked her about um
[Music]
the criminal history record check and
she said yes some schools ask about that
and she makes sure that whatever drivers
that drive
for
um
that school
that they have that
they're done
but that is done through the bus company
not like this wants to do through the
doe i mean the doe has no jurisdiction
over
commercial bus lines or coach lines and
so the coach companies will do that and
she said they would only if the school
says
we want the drivers to pass this she
said she just make sure that whatever
driver she sends she has on record
you know that she's done a
um
yes criminal background check and she
has that record in the in the bus
company
and look at some other things
so a number i mean even the number of
the things that are written in here
she's like
yeah they're not allowed on the road
unless they do these things so they're
already in both federal and state
regulations
the other thing
is
that um
both lukak and i agreed on is that
these coaches just by virtue of
what they are and how they're made are
much safer
than a school bus anyways
and they certainly have a lot they're a
lot more designed for highways and
the drivers have a lot more hours
driving on highways and this is what
we're talking about is highway trips
another thing that i discovered in this
is that um
like our middle school
for the ski club actually uses coaches
and i was surprised and they said yeah
because then they can put all the gear
underneath instead of having it in the
bus and i know when i chaperoned on a
school bus from milford
they piled all the stuff in the back of
the bus and every time the bus went
around to the porter it would shift and
caught into the aisle in front of the
exit you know the rear exit it was very
not safe and so the idea of the coach
and storing it underneath instead of
having it piled up in the back of the
bus
because yes i would go back and keep
stacking it back in the seats but in the
case of an accident
that's going all over the place and it
would be blocking the emergency exit
anyways
so
but and and
we couldn't find
where it actually
made it illegal
we think it was maybe by the mission and
that it didn't make it legal and so
people have been doing this both
coaches and schools for years and years
as you know
we haven't had problems with it
um everybody was kind of blown away with
what you mean this is illegal and so the
idea this amendment is to
make it legal
and
if schools want to put
you know leave it as a local option
because we're always talking about local
options the school wants to put higher
requirements on the bus company they can
do that
and choose a bus company that's willing
to
um
do the things that they're asking
so that's oh and the other thing was
just
you know it said 75 at least 75 miles
before
and so we just changed it to 150 round
trip because
there was that 75th street around trip
so that was the only difference in the
amendment
and i'd be happy to take any questions
because i did a lot of research
thank you very much uh for all that
information
questions
steve you're muted thank you thank you
very much i apologize uh thank you
chairman appreciate the chance to just
speak a moment uh as representative
lucas did say we did spend an anointed
amount of time going over all these
regulation research in them and and she
did a wonderful job checking the bud
services however i was surprised to see
this amendment because i thought our
agreement had been that we believed it
needed more work
uh and all we've done here is exclude
part three the 75 mile piece i
wasn't mistaken i thought we agreed as a
testimony did it had to be 75 was a
round trip but my bigger concern is that
in this amendment as it now is presented
my concern of the whole amendment was
part three that dealt with the carriers
and the safety checks record checks for
carriers for drivers uh and that's been
eliminated because as she as she
indicated we couldn't come to agreement
nor could we uh figured how was going to
happen we thought it needed more time to
develop the input as it is now where
they've on
on line
11 and 12 of the amendment
um that brought forward it eliminates
uh the requirement for bus driver
certification which was on line 36 and
37 in the in the original bill
and i still think that's very critical
because that that is that requiring the
school department to do uh in the buses
to make sure that that no one there is a
felon
no one there is a pedophile no one there
is a drug dealer
as
as i suggest they probably aren't for
the cdl but that's the whole intent of
having the the last part and that was
the part that uh representative lucas
and i had more difficulty with i thought
we're going to try to rework
over the summer because there has to be
a way in my mind that we may ensure that
the bus drivers who are driving students
meet those requirements and that's
that's part of what the uh
in the original bill
uh
required so i i do appreciate her effort
on this and our effort because it did
take a lot of time and research uh and i
will as a side note by the way the rsa
books that we had from four years ago
don't have all the new bills in them but
that that being said uh the reality is
under 23 263 29a which is the
certificate
uh which has been eliminated i think is
major issues and we shouldn't eliminate
that and and i would much prefer to
to retain this
or uh
retain this uh so we can correct it uh
because part three as it is now it just
says okay we're just gonna say we know
it's wrong we know it's been illegal so
now we're just gonna say it's okay legal
which i think is gonna come down to bite
us later on when something happens
because all we've done is sort of
circumvent the issue and not corrected
it
so
that's what that's my opinion
representative ladd
thank you
represent bone thank you
we can't just be taken
you have to retain the whole bill so i
think if somebody thinks
it needs more work
then fine do more work and come back
with another bill next year but we can't
just retain one section we have to
maintain the whole bill
right which is why i
remember we had talked about either
eliminating the whole thing or making it
legal and then putting more stringent
regulations if we can figure out how to
do it next year and so that was um
[Music]
that was the way this went let's make
sure that kids schools can legally do
what they've been doing all this time
without problems
and then if we think their potential
potentially problems add that
next year add that piece of legislation
in if we can find out by meeting with
all of those people
how to do
criminal record checks
but i think they're going to have to
belong to the coach companies and not
the doe
um
and as i said
some schools do that now
so a school who's not who's concerned or
doesn't trust the coach company
they can request it and of the coaches
now and they do
for their discussion
just one one follow-up one followed by
manchester chair go ahead
my follow-up is i'm concerned when we
pass this this uh change with just cdls
we're never going to see it back again
and once we allow the requirements for
the the uh
school bus driver certification to be
removed that means anytime a youngster
gets on a regular bus it's just a cdlo
bus it's going to be any bus in the
world i think we're making a mistake um
so
if representative bone i assume is
correct he knows more than i then take
the whole part three out and fix it but
i i just think this is an error for
opening the door for all kinds of
potential issues letting any driver
drive our kids we don't do it in the
yellow buses but now i say we're gonna
take we don't care about the background
of that driver when they're doing the
cdl's so i think that's a big big error
thank you rep senator cornelli thank you
i would just comment that i think the
door is wide open now
yep that's true
i like us yeah we've been doing this for
years as you all know we've been doing
this for years
and so all this is doing is is saying
recognizing we've been doing this for
years and
yes it's legal to go ahead and do it um
but as far as taking out the school bus
driver's certificate i talked to a
number of bus companies and they were
like
they're not going to be able to to
require their drivers to have school bus
driver certificates as well they're not
driving school buses they're driving
coaches and that has its own set of
requirements and training and stuff and
remember one of the things i was
concerned about that caused us to go and
look at this is
drivers are only allowed to drive a
certain number of hours and then they
have to have a relief driver and you
can't write
this rule in
and expect that some
driver in north carolina that they are
relieving the bus yes it's going to be
with the same company but are they going
to have our school bus driver
at least well two of the companies
basically said if you put that in what's
going to happen is coaches just aren't
going to
work with the schools
they have a hard enough time signing
cdls and we have a hard enough time
finding school bus drivers and to try to
have to find somebody with both the cdl
and the school bus driver certificate
just really
okay rex and whitcock final comment
those six words we've always done it
this way to not justify continuing doing
it
thank you represent tanner
at at one point in my career
uh the school bus
group decided that coaches of small
teams like tennis
uh could their teacher the coach
could get certified
to drive the small school bus
and um
so i ended up being a bus driver for a
little bit
and it really wasn't um the requirement
the requirements for getting a school
bus license
was mainly the cdl
which fortunately because i had those
small vans i didn't have to do
but basically it's just uh you know
making sure you had a clean record
uh making sure that uh you were healthy
enough that you weren't gonna you know
have a heart attack on the on the bus
trip i mean it it really wasn't that and
the criminal background check i mean it
isn't like
um
you know you have to learn to turn the
bus around or whatever and anyway the
guys that do the cdl stuff they would
know that you know from that so i don't
think the uh
the actual certification for school bus
driver is that rigorous and certainly
they are hurting for school bus drivers
so they've made it really
um
not easy but they've made it
really
easy to get
to the certification and and
they want to put people through that
so i'm not sure that
it sounds it sounds like you think that
school bus certification is a really
tough
thank you
representative ford
yes thank you mr chair
i'm wondering if the solution lies to
move the testing or the
security issue from the school board
driver to someone who's accompanying the
students and that person being required
to be with the students anytime they're
in contact with the bus driver so if you
go to north carolina and pick up another
driver they just
someone is always with the from your
group is always with the bus driver so
that that would prevent any kind of
unpoured activities and
you've done the same thing without
requiring the bus company to have all of
its drivers up and down the seashore
have these background checks
thank you very much
further discussion
[Music]
i don't
i don't see anybody uh madam clerk can
you call the role on on this amendment
1555 h
ought to pass
representative cordelli
yes representative baum
yes
representative notter
representative
yes
representative hobson yes
representative andres
sorry about that i didn't unmute myself
yes
representative ford
yes representative leon
yes
representative saudi
resemblance no
representative luna
no
representative shaw votes no
representative cornell no
representative tanner
no
representative ellison
representative mullin
no
representative uh porter
representative woodcock you
representative lad yes
are there any other amendments for
part two part three excuse part three
we don't need a minority reporter you
don't have to do that right now the
person that knows a little bit more
about the
the part
might talk to the person making that
final motion and incorporate that all in
like different paragraphs within the
ominous bill report
okay
okay um going on to part four here
uh part four deals with uh relative to
additional state aid for special
education
for certain communities of one thousand
for fewer residents
and relative to special education risk
from leon you're recognized for a motion
thank you mr chair i would like to move
okay thank you very much
so we have a motion made by representing
leon and second by rep represent bone uh
uh on
uh amendment for part four that's
fifteen fifty nine grabs and lay on to
care to speak the emotion uh yes thank
you mr chair
this language is enabling language to
offer solutions to a clear and pressing
need as we discussed in committee
two-thirds of special education funding
comes from the local level
we also know that budgets are set before
the beginning of the school year and
that even a single unexpected special
education student would have a
devastating impact on budgets
this amendment is sorry today this is
addressed two ways there's catastrophic
aid from the state and there's
self-insurance at the local level
last year local school districts set
aside six million dollars for this exact
risk
starting at section two we have a
well-studied study purely voluntary way
for school districts to join together to
spread the risk of unexpected costs
today we have the software and data
needed to make this happen
this data has a shelf life so if we are
going to ever offer this option now
that's fine
the time is now
worst case is the districts don't see a
value to this and don't join together to
form these pools
if the pools don't offer them a value
then there's no harm no foul all we've
done is passed a bill
anybody to do anything
this all enabling language
if they do find this valuable though we
can solve a big issue with school school
budgets where they can have a 300 000
student come into the district at the
last moment that's hard enough for a
district like derry to absorb there's
others with where that's absolutely fast
so i that's why i moved on to pass on
this amendment and i think that this
would be very helpful for our schools
thank you very much representative you
need the second you can't speak on it no
no further discussion
representative
oh thank you thank you mr chairman
now this was uh my opening comment this
morning this was one of the pieces that
i was
disappointed to see in this amendment
we as a committee
did consider this issue
as a matter of fact we had a substantive
conversation about this issue
i thought we had come to the conclusion
that
this may be a good idea
but we need to have more study in this
and it was my understanding that as a
committee we had concluded that we
needed to have this more of a study and
that we needed to look at in the next
session
to see it in this amendment is
disappointing because we don't have that
opportunity to do the due diligence
around this issue before we
provide a piece of legislation
we need to have this due diligence in
order that the legislation can in fact
be reflective of those issues the those
states that have done similar kinds of
things and have learned from it we have
we have no history here in the state
about this so i'm disappointed that that
this is part of this amendment and i
will not support this based upon the
conversation and the understanding that
i thought we had as a committee prior to
representation
thank you mr chair i will note that the
bill that this was in was heard by our
committee passed by our committee and
passed on the floor they ran out of time
and finance so they retained it but this
is something that we did have
substantial diagram dialogue and i
absolutely remember that conversation
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair um representative
lyon i remember hearing this bill of
parts of this bill when i was
substituting in finance can you tell me
what the result was from the finance
committee
thank you yes it was retained
there was a lot of work that was being
done on the budget
thank you
very much for the follow-up yes earlier
you said that it had passed this
yes it did made it to finance otherwise
okay thank you
613 originated in this body right here
the education committee went on to the
house floor was voted on and was sent to
finance
uh representative
yeah my understanding this is actually
the amendment that i was expecting based
on conversation we had on thursday
and
my understanding was that
yes finance was going to be working on
it and we were waiting for the final
result
um
and that if we got
the wording in time it would go into
this amendment and apparently we didn't
get that in time because
it's in this amendment it's exactly what
i was expecting from the conversations
that we had on thursday so
i don't know
apparently various of us were in the
same meeting but we weren't
further comments representative mullen
uh
with to representative lakers's comments
i i remember no conversation about the
insurance risk pool
uh last week at all so perhaps that took
place in your caucus but i don't believe
that it took place uh with the full
committee
and i base my my opinion on the fact
that there is another amendment to part
four which i authored
uh dealing with the first part which was
the 250 000
that we learned has not been tapped into
for districts in need
um
at no point in time when i was working
on that amendment was i even considering
the insurance risk pool and i was
shocked as representative milor
mentioned to see it attached to part one
because my amendment of course now would
reference part one and part two but was
intended to uh eliminate part one
thank you
i might add that when we did discuss
this in 613 in this committee
we had a healthy discussion on it
we were informed that there was an
actuarial firm out in kansas that had
done a calculator for us but and for the
department of education
and i heard testimony from our
discussion when we had it in hearing
that
it was a good idea and i heard that from
both sides four parties uh a follow-up
which mr truman
mike my issue is not with whether or not
it's a good idea or a bad idea my issue
is with the fact that we had tons of
unanswered questions and while the bill
may have gone through
it went through uh to give it a chance
to get to finance who retained it
from my perspective to get answers to
those questions
so that we could look with knowledge at
what we were doing before we made a
legitimate vote on whether or not we
were making a seismic shift in how we uh
reimburse for unexpected special aid
costs
so i i just i i i
i'm shocked that this is back before us
without us having any discussion about
the answers to the many many questions
further discussion from representatives
oh i just
was
with the whether or not this was there
i was thinking oh well maybe it was side
conversations or whatever but it
occurred to me i was on the zoo meeting
last time i wasn't here and i missed our
caucus last week so the only place i
could have heard it
was here was you know the same place you
were on the zoo meeting and this is
exactly what i was expecting so i was
really surprised when
when comments were made about this
coming out of the blue i'm like wait a
minute we talked about this
and yes i have the same
[Music]
thanks very much mr chair um no i mean
this this amen you know the amendment
that you're putting forward today is
exactly how it came into this committee
uh when we were executing the um uh the
underlying bill um i i forget the bill
number 631 something like that
uh uh back uh back a couple months ago
it was brought up at exec there was
never a hearing uh held on the um
the um uh you know the idea of of having
a risk pool
for special education costs
um you know i'm concerned that um
that that a lot of the people that uh
that we rely on for for good information
such as the
school administrators association school
board association
the special education administrators
association municipal association and
others haven't had any opportunity to
provide any testimony on this and that
at that exact session which uh which
representative leakas was just referring
to because the only other time we've um
uh we've seen this language uh in front
of us that that there was heavy reliance
put on the finance committee that they
would give this
um um a financial
element of of of this policy change a
thorough vetting which obviously they
didn't do so so you know i i think i
think this is offering it again here
is is
is
just in you know
on its face
um um conflicting with with even
the um um
even mr chair your rationale uh months
ago on the on the uh the bill you sought
to amend then that it would that it
would have a um
you know a solid vetting in the finance
committee so i i really think this is
not ready for prime time
representative porter
yes mr chair thank you for allowing me
to speak i just got off the phone with
representative heath um i worked that i
worked with on the subcommittee that
worked on this bill
and we did retain it in um finance and
no report has gone out yet
so um i think it was stated earlier that
now that we have the information from
finance we can move forward but
that's not happened so um
[Music]
not seeing any other further discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
this is on amendment
h
and it is
representative cordelli
yes
represented bone yes
representative uh nodder yes
representative likus
yes
president moffett
representative hobson yes representative
andrus
yes representative ford
yes
representative leon
yes representative soti yes
i'll wait
mr chair
representative andres answered i did not
see her on the screen
she might want to
vote right there i've seen her on the
screen each time she's right here she no
she was black when when i saw her
let's go on with a little call here
please
representative miler
no
representative luno
no i guess who cares if it works or not
representative shaw no representative
cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison no
representative mullen
no representative uh
porter
no
representative woodcock
you
representative lad
yes
this is a surprise
okay
representative cornelli
i would like to move on to cash with an
amendment on house bill sp 46 which
means sb 147
and that includes amendments 1537 h
1555 h and
1559 h
i'll second that
don't don't you have another amendment
yeah point point of order mr chair oh
i'm sorry yeah okay i didn't see it yeah
um is that representative mullins
go ahead i didn't see that i would i
would make the motion that we uh ought
to pass
and i would be happy to speak to the
amendment oh i didn't hear a second who
seconded that
i'll i'll second that hey
hey
okay uh representative would you go
ahead please
sure uh when i initially proposed this
amendment it was because i had uh
serious concerns with
section one of part four which was the
allocation of two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to towns with less than
a thousand people to use in unexpected
special education costs
my concerns were over the fact that we
heard testimony last thursday that these
funds were not being uh
tapped into by communities and so the
idea that we were going to add an
additional 250 000
when the original allocation of 250 000
was not being utilized did not make a
whole lot of sense
it seemed to uh have problems in its
distribution in widening disparity
and we did not have a solution on what
to do with cooperative school districts
so that was my initial concern
but since the amendment came in that
added the insurance risk pool to the
bill i have many many more concerns and
i'm just going to mention some of them
i'm concerned about the choice process
how the five uh districts come together
i'm concerned about the idea
that they're supposed to be diverse in
terms of geographic region and size but
nobody talks about
who's going to who's going to make those
decisions representative you're speaking
to the the bill as amended that first
amendment and this particular amendment
deals with section one of part four
we're talking about the 250 000.
so
uh
am i
i mean the the
amendment
specifies deleting all of part four
we have just
passed an amendment that expands part
four
to include the risk pool
so i am under the assumption that if i
am making a a motion to get rid of part
four that i can now speak to both parts
of it
yeah you're you're speaking to of course
you're in 1588
and you're speaking my amendment is to
do away with part four which we just
amended
you're talking about amending section
one within part four then then if you're
saying down below amend the bill by
deleting part four
looks to me like you're doing two
different things
uh well no because we changed the bill
go ahead and speak to uh amending the
entire bill by deleting that we'll just
get down to the bottom line here
all right so uh again i will go on and
say that i'm concerned about the process
of how the risk pools are going to be
formed and who is going to make the
determination on the district size
geographic region and whether or not a
risk pool is diverse
i'm concerned about what happens with
school districts that already have high
special education costs and whether or
not they're going to be chosen to be
on the team
if you will if they already have high
costs
i'm concerned about
who is going to protect student
confidential information because in the
bill it repeatedly says that that
information will be
protected to the extent that is possible
but it doesn't define that
and i am very concerned about the fact
that
for the first five years the costs of
all of this the uh filing fees the
request for proposal education and
training the actuarial services and cost
predictor spreadsheet will be the
responsibility of the department of
education but after five years the risk
pool itself has to assume the cost of
all of those things
we don't know what those costs are going
to be we've had no estimate whatsoever
what that price tag is going to look
like and that ta that price is going to
get given back to the taxpayer because
the risks pools themselves are going to
have to pay for this
so
um i i now believe that that this
amendment speaks to uh deleting part
four
i thought it was a good idea originally
i think it's a better idea now
and uh i
i see the microphone
thank you further discussion
representative porter
thank you mr chair um i agree with
representative mullen there's no money
in the budget to fund the department of
education assuming these costs and i'm
sure that was one of the things that was
considered when the finance committee
further discussion represent like this
yeah at
first i was liking
um brett mullen's amendment because
i wasn't big on the
thought it was unnecessary
for the extra 250 000 but
it doesn't say they're going to put it
aside it says they may
designate up to 250 000
so basically if there turns out to be a
need
it has not been foreseen
that option is available it may never
get used just like not much of the other
250 000 has been used but
you can't foresee so it's again it's
just enabling
it is not actually spending that money
but i do
like that second part
the risk management association i think
long term
that is the way to go
and
that will i think eliminate a lot of the
problems with funding special needs
and so for that reason
i
decided i would support the past last
amendment
specifically because of that second part
that was put in there
but yeah as far as the first part
okay further discussion on
on this part or this amendment
i'm not seeing any hands up except yours
alicia's
i'm sorry
okay so madam clerk would you please
amendment this is ought to pass on
representative baum
no
representative
notter
no
representative lacus
representative moffitt
no
representative hobson
representative andres
no
representative ford
representative lyon
no
representative sodie
representative milor
yes
representative luno
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
representative tanner
yes
representative ellison
representative mullen yes
representative porter
yes
representative woodcock yes
representative ladd no
okay so now represent cordelia will you
amended for house bill
senate bill 147
including amendments
1537 to part 1
to part 3
and 1559
to part four
is there a second
second represent bone seconds the motion
represent cordell you like to speak the
emotion
uh i
think we've had enough discussions
of course i've just been courteous thank
you i appreciate it you're welcome i'm
repson boom
wow do you want to talk about the
vikings
okay um
not the football team either
any further discussion represent cornell
yes so we're voting on all four parts
with the three amendments we're voting
on the final bill as amended by these
okay madame clerk
um just uh mr chair yes just
clarification i want to make sure that
um that that we have a minority position
on on senate bill 147 which i think
would likely be
um ought to pass as amended with the one
you can still identify that after this
vote okay but i just wanted to yeah i
just want to make sure i got that on the
record that we didn't lose an
opportunity
in front of the horse here
okay go ahead uh represent sean
representative cordelli
yes
representative bone
yes representative um
yes
representative lacus yes
representative moffitt
yes
representative hobson
representative andres yes representative
ford
yes
representative lyon
representative soti yes
representative milor
no
representative luno no representative
shaw no representative cornell no
but representative tanner no
representative ellison
no
representative mullin no
representative uh porter no
representative woodcock new
representative lad yes
11 9.
okay so we are now done uh sb 147 we're
gonna take about a five minute break
here for folks to walk down the hallway
a little bit here
and for you all to take a little break
too stretch your legs and then we'll
representative uh
luna will do the minority report on that
that's fine
mr chair
yes before we start so that i can do it
in the break um i have in front of me
two amendments proposed for rep uh 148
rep lad and cordelli an amendment uh
2021-1585h
representative uh presented by rep luno
are there any more amendments to this
bill
yes that i don't have yes there are we
have uh
i see four amendments for their that
bill
five total
yes yes ma'am
i'll send over to you representative
porter
1584h 1580h and
1586h those are the others that i have
thank you very much thank you very much
jen
okay let's take a short break let's
stretch about 10 minutes because
just going to go ahead and mute the room
right now
hey
all set
did um
just for
a few minutes
um
now
okay
yes
me
and
okay
beautiful
you
stupid
[Music]
hopefully
louise can you hear us
yes
okay is do we have everybody everybody
okay let's go ahead and continue now on
our last bill for today sb 148
and sb 148 is uh omnibus bill
legislation relative to vocational
career education environmental education
and emergency plans for special sports
injuries
so with that um
let's go down through the parks here and
i am not seeing an amendment for part
one anybody have a hidden amendment on
i don't see any hands so
we're done with part one
all right
thank you thank you mr chair i i don't i
don't have an amendment on part one but
i do have a question i i when we had the
discussion with the people from the
department of ed i asked a question
about
one of the parts that was being repealed
in part one and from what they sent over
i can't seem to make get an answer from
that so i'm not quite sure
where i should bring that up
do you have the letter that came in from
lisa
yes i do
it has the underlying areas within it
that's correct
okay so that doesn't help you out
uh it doesn't appear to no okay
can you before we go much farther then
let's
what's what's your concern are
number it's rsa 200-c
[Music]
column 13 relative to insufficient funds
and my question was
i i would like some context because it
appears that this bill is repealing
that particular part uh
and
i want to know what impact repealing
that particular part would have
the letter from lisa talks about
two major
programs being affected the other nine
or
the other
statutory provisions are being repealed
so i have the same question they started
with what is the impact of repealing
the section related to relative to
insufficient funds okay
i hear you uh lisa is there in our
attendee list
maybe we could bring her up from the
department
she's
uh hi there representative land
committee
good afternoon
did you lisa did you hear our
representatives uh
query
i did um i did uh representative ellison
and
what what i could surmise from all of
the research that i have done on this
this week is that this entire program um
which includes um 200 c9
through uh 200 c14 or c15 rather
is for the workers personal care
assistance program
and what we could surmise with the
research we did was that this program
was moved
between 1986 and 1994
to hhs
but it was only moved
to utilize personal care attendant
services during
at home in-home services
not at work
and
so there's been no funding for this
program from either a federal or a state
uh entity that we could surmise for all
these years
this is
what i would say as well as this is a
natural service that would be included
on a vocational rehabilitation
individual plan for employment so if an
individual
wanted to go to work they needed a pca a
personal care attendant to go to work
we could absolutely add that in as a
service on their plan for employment and
so
you know we have a service
mechanism for providing this service
there is no additional you know
federal funding or state funding
for to provide personal care attendance
at work
so in other words medicaid will not pay
for a pca at work they will only pay for
it at home
so what we could uh what we could glean
from this is that you know
you know back in the 80s this was a
program um i did talk to one of my staff
uh that was around ella mcallister
during that time and she indicated she
did remember a couple folks
utilizing um this provision but when
they went away it's sort of like you
know there
there was no there was no real need for
it and then as the vr program has
evolved
um
we didn't we didn't need a specific
legislative
program to do this work we can do it in
our normal business practices
representative
thank you mr chair um
i i have not seen the letter and i so
and i wasn't expecting to be back today
so or i would have pursued it further um
lisa can you tell me then what about um
the first number one rsa 200 c7 that has
to do with the deaf telecommunication
equipment can you give me an answer to
my concern about that yeah so um this is
uh so this is a program that was
transferred to uh the governor's
commission on disability
from the vr program and again
unfortunately there was no
legislative history on sort of when that
happened
so this is a program that is fully
functioning
it's a program that is actually derived
from the public utilities commission
and the public public utilities
commission has in their statute that
this program is administered by the
governor's commission on disability
the governor's commission on disability
has administrative rules
for administering the program
um and so
all of these um all the
telecommunications equipment programs
um now are uh
actually served by the future insight
administered there so so unfortunately
when the program was moved we didn't do
any repeal of our statute
in that process so i hope that helps
yes it does and i was just wondering if
you were able to contact or if the
commission on deafness and um hearing
loss had made any contact
at all about this
uh no but i did uh have a conversation
representative with chuck say just to
solidify my understanding
of the move um and and ensure that um
that i had this correct um what i will
also add um i know
i had asked chuck say to be to be here
and i know he was here this morning but
um that program can the
telecommunications equipment access
program can be utilized by individuals
who are deaf and hard of hearing as well
as individuals who are blind and
visually impaired and have physical
disabilities right right yeah okay thank
you i thank you for answering my
questions i appreciate it makes me
reassured no problem
lisa does that uh funding for that
program come from medicaid schools
uh for the telecommunications program
that for the uh 200 home seven that the
communications equipment
um
no um that so
again that's a program that com
the funding comes from puc
so it's it's a from what i understand
it's a federal it's a federal program
that um
[Music]
that is provided for folks to have
access
so if you have a classroom that needs
that equipment within
for a disabled student child
does the school make the requests
through the department or and does it
come from from the department or does it
come from
some other the governor's commission on
disability
um
i mean we typically don't get a lot of
requests from the schools
uh the the schools i mean they
in terms of
i mean i could get sort of i could get
an understanding of the requests that
come into them but i'd have to reach out
to future insight
to determine you know how the schools do
that
i apologize that i don't know that off
the top of my head
well you know it's you know i guess part
one of this bill has been more
perplexing to me than any other thing
we've discussed today in terms of
trying to figure out what's going on
um
so i guess i'm gonna just take your word
yeah i i mean i guess
the only thing i can say representative
is
um
i i feel very strongly that the
telecommunication needs of individuals
with disabilities
um are well
addressed
in terms of uh
in terms of employment i mean we can
help people with anything they need um
and if it is something for their home
that's really where that
telecommunications equipment program
comes in
um and as well with the work with the
workers personal care assistance program
um we can provide those services
on a plan for employment and so in other
words there's really there's no need for
a legislative
statute to do that because it's in our
normal business
now i i understand that i can remember
discussing this years ago when we had
the the equipment had to remain in the
home but the school also needed it yeah
and is medicaid paying for both sets of
equipment or uh
is there another budget that we're
having to take that money out of to pay
for the stuff in the schools that's
always been my question yeah
yeah and um i could i could send a note
to one of my colleagues in special ed um
and and ask them um while you guys are
continuing
that that'd be fine okay
uh
yes thank you one last follow-up on on
this section 200 c13
uh if it's not repealed
then on this question to lisa
what is the impact if this is not
repealed and it stays in legislation
um
if it wasn't repealed
you know we would have to develop rules
for this program because they don't
currently exist in our rules and our
administrative rules
um
and
you know we would we would utilize our
vocational rehabilitation grant to
provide any services that anyone asked
for
um so
you know we would do whatever we had to
i think it's
programmatically easier if it if it is
repealed because we do this in normal
business as it stands
thank you
thank you very much further questions uh
lisa on this uh part one
uh rep sales and your hand's still up
are you sorry i'm sorry mr chairman
that's fine no problem
we're finished with part one it was nick
we don't have any amending language for
that we're leaving the way it is
part two
uh relative to career and technical
education
to represent cordelia so i can make a
motion
thank you mr chairman um
character in motion part two yes i'd
like to uh move on to pass and then uh
with amendment 1563
okay um
i've i have reviewed this amendment
before with uh our our committee
and i i think folks should be pretty
much familiar with what we're doing here
if we're dealing with
uh the expansion replacement of
facilities etc but that that's the way
the bill came forward to us
we've added on the base of the first
page of part two
new hampshire students are encouraged to
access career and technical education to
learn and apply technical academic
employability skills needed for career
prayer and life
um
and going on down the transportation is
really the big big thing we're trying to
do within this
we recognize the transportation's not
fully funded
i've given you the figures before we
allocate 9 million bucks total for
transportation and tuition
of which back in the year that we got
this data
approximately 680 thousand dollars was
paid in for transportation to the school
districts the actual cost was closer to
2.6 million dollars and so this was uh
certainly a cost which we're handing
down to the cte for cte
attendance
and uh working with um
with folks on the other side of the wall
in the senate
we've added in subject to availability
of funding
and
the i guess the
biggest part of this bill
is to me at least is on line six on page
two where the students resident district
shall be responsible for providing
transportation not the sending district
so this makes provides eligibility to
the three districts that no longer
receive that have not received any
transportation funding
exeter nashua and manchester
it further goes down and says if a
student is permitted to self-transport
the students resident district shall
reimburse the student in accordance with
rules adopted pursuant to rsa 541a
that is in our rules right now and we we
reimburse i believe it's at 25 cents per
mile
the the school districts for bus
transportation i get reimbursed 10 cents
a mile
the
this is for those few students that may
drive themselves to the cte center
it may be cheaper to provide one car to
go
than uh one big bus
and in some cte centers the kids stay
after school close is to work
in an apprenticeship or an internship
right there in the community the ct is
located in so they come home later at a
later hour then the bus will pick them
up
that has to be approved by the local
school district the high school
much of that came to us uh on pages two
and three from there on
um going on page
four
uh we're putting on to that uh
that the council uh the chancellor of
the community college system
and um
we're putting on the uh chancellor of
the community college system of new
hampshire or designee advanced
manufacturing council so that's
welcome
um
uh online uh 23 on page four
uh where we've uh in the past when we're
talking about dual and concurrent
enrollment programs
we have provided uh stem courses science
technology engineering and math but it's
come from the folks on the advisory
council
as well as many people in the high
schools that communication skills are
equally as important as a specific skill
so by putting the language in here in
here
and support doing
career technical education courses
um and it goes down on line 25
then 24-25 that are fundamental and
necessary for success in the
post-secondary education career path
opportunity opportunities
and to meet new hampshire's emerging
workforce needs so they could take the
course of communication which has been
advocated by the
folks at the cte centers and lastly
by inserting on line 30
grade 10 high schools now
allow kids that have been students that
are in grades 10 11 and 12 we reduced it
from 11 to 12 to 10 11 12
to participate in this program now we're
providing it also to the cte programs
um
i guess that's it for the amendment
language and this that's
some of it's most of it was here before
when we got it you've heard the changes
mr chair
yes what about section
yeah i'm not sure that was in the
original bill but
if i made it with section 14 in the
original bill yeah it's there we did not
and that's not part of this amendment
okay
okay um
you made the second on that should care
to speak to it
i think you did a good job pointing out
the differences
and explaining why they're in there so
further discussion on this from some
iowa
uh thank you mr chair could you explain
to me how you see
i'm looking at page one excuse me
on line 28 the new language that new
hampshire students are encouraged
to access career and tech edu how do you
see that happening
well
to go back to work the history on that
is it came out of
the department and the advisory council
that students have the right
to cte
education um that came under some
discussion within the senate and they
and
as i was told by senator uh
waters um so what we're trying to do
there is we're trying to beef up the
number of kids
that are going to the cte centers uh
due to the transportation issues we have
really limited the number of students in
fact some districts are allocating we
got 10 seats
and the 14 kids want to go four of them
are
are not going uh what we're trying to do
is we had a sheet that was handed to us
oh months ago months ago when we were
discussing tuition and transportation i
uh compared it to the state of delaware
where their percentage in attendance was
much much higher than ours here
and they have approximately the same
number of students
and and of course the whole funding
system is much different as well
but uh we need to if we're going to
provide skills or the workforce numbers
that we are required to provide to
support our manufacturers and industry
and various businesses
we need to encourage and we're hoping
that the counselors and schools will
recognize that fact and i think they're
doing a good job since we've had
counselor
counselors on the council one and that's
been a real benefit um
we can always do better though
follow up please um
i know that that in some of these
schools there there are limits
and in some areas there are i have no
problem with the language but
uh has the advisory council
looked at the issue that if they get
expanded students
where they have limited sources already
and there's a lottery for those students
to attend have they talked about
how
the actual cte center is going to expand
the options there if in fact there
currently are limited options
and you've got with this language there
may be more students who want to attend
well i i agree we have been limiting our
students and unfortunately so uh this is
why we're we're trying
and it's it comes down to finance that's
where it goes now uh it's going to come
down as a financial issue that we
provide the money and just as we do
sometimes in special education with the
old cad aide now speciality we allocate
x number of dollars be at 30 million or
where wherever we may be and if we have
more students coming in the amount that
we reimburse is is of course shrunk
because we have to spread it amongst
more kids the same thing's happening in
cte programs when we allocate this nine
million dollars each year so uh then
we're in and uh
that's going to there's eventually going
to be an issue here and uh
we need to bring this to the forefront
in terms of how we are funding and how
we are supporting career technical
education that's why we had that uh i
can't remember the bill number two
because i think one of the first bills
was signed by the governor to set up the
commission or the committee for looking
at tuition and transportation which we
need to get going um
so
i understand the question uh i
understand though that we have to
resolve several things first i think
we've got to resolve the issue of nashua
exeter and manchester
and get them on the boards as far as
receiving transportation monies then
there's going to be a question and of
course this is why
legislation such as this has been turned
down in the past
seeing that the transportation
comes out of that nine million dollars
each year the remainder is used for
tuition
and so if you use more for
transportation it's gonna be less
tuition reimbursement
um what we've got to do is in order to
make this work
according to the department eric for
worth we're probably going to allocate
another 2 million each year for cte
programs
representatives
yeah in regards to that question that
you just had
i did talk to the coordinator at auburn
cte in hudson
um
last year
and he said that there were programs
that were not being utilized
and um his biggest suggestion was making
sure that all of the guidance counselors
understood what all the options were so
a way of
encouraging access would be to make sure
that all of the guidance councils know
just what all programs are available and
to get it out to their
kids and so that was
we're up against a real mountain in
terms of career technical education
understanding that tuition in some
schools can be as low as three thousand
dollars other schools can be up as high
as seven thousand dollars per kid
interpretation how many hours they have
to be at a cte program are different
between new hampshire and uh connecticut
and and vermont
in order to get credit for the course so
there's a whole lot of issues which the
director is now looking at trying to get
some uh
coordinated uh commonality here between
the the programs all all the 20 plus cte
incentives
uh any further represent porter
yes thank you mr chair i noticed that we
changed the effective date
way down on page number five
line 27 from june 2022 to 2026 and i'm
wondering
just curious why
such a big jump it's done by doa
and and it's because we're we're looking
at
budget issues with this
uh appropriating dollars
and um
we don't expect uh some of these schools
really get on board as quickly as they
are
great 11 and 12 kids 10th grade kids
will come gradually and they'll have to
you're going to have to have the
prerequisites to get into the dual and
concurrent enrollment that's in this
program as well
do we have anybody up from this career
technical education here listening
i don't think so
[Music]
there is
jay khan is
a member there
and i don't know if he he's he's
diana fenton's there also
yeah would you like me to
know
we can try i don't know if she's gonna
good afternoon um i appreciate the
confidence in me but um
you are correct cte falls outside of my
area of expertise
uh but i did
send a message to eric and uh he is
quickly getting back to me so i hope to
have that answer for you shortly
thank you
did you just um he just
emailed me back and i'm going to send
him the link to the zoom meeting
and you should have your answer shortly
okay
thank you very much yeah
thank you
hey rick with if we've got diana still
on the
yeah go ahead in the meeting thanks um
there may be a simple answer to this i'm
just not putting it together but down
down where um representative porter was
talking about the change in effective
date section 18
um
and then on line 27 it goes section
three of this act actually it says um i
think that's a roman
i think it's a roman one
um section three of this act shall take
effect june 30th 2026. what's being
that's that
that's on the first page
no that's not
that's not the same section three that
it's referring to i don't think that
because they're talking about amending
i think 2019 247 colon 4 is the is house
i think that's the budget document
you know i i don't have an answer for
you on that this is you know this has
been developed by by them
right
but but it's being amended by us yeah i
yes basically
you see what i'm saying that i don't
think it refers to section three on page
one is diana
still there could she try to find eric
i think it refers to section three
on page three
we do have mr crowe with welcome to
hello eric um we're dealing with uh the
part of 148 which deals with career
technical education part two
okay we're looking at the uh repeal
dates effective dates
and do you understand or know why we're
talking about uh repealing once apart at
online 24 2026.
in section three also references 2026
the other i see referencing you know you
so the the line 24
is the the the original legislation that
senator waters wrote for the tax
donations sunsetted in 2022
and in this amendment he was asking to
i got it yes that's what that piece is
um
[Music]
i'm not sure what line 27 refers to
though
so is that just reacting so as
oh so so in june 30th 2026 it gets
repealed
that what gets repealed
the the tax credit allotment
so 247 4
is part of that
the tax credit allotment
okay so it's it's related to
um to lines 23 and 24 24 i believe so
the
as i'm not unfortunately i'm not looking
at the original but the original law i
there is the repeal law that says
effective
june 30th 2022
this portion of the cte law will be
repealed which is
the
granting tax credit so this was changing
i think that's how senator waters
explained it to me but between now and
then and now i had forgotten that
sounds like that answers it rick though
and i'm sure in 2024
we'll come back to you and ask to extend
another four years don't worry i'm sure
you will
um
one other thing eric there was a
question and i i
tried to answer that on the first page
where we had a new hampshire student are
encouraged to access career technical
education at one point in time you folks
and the council were talking about uh
new hampshire students have a right
right
and that that was discussed i believe on
this in the senate side was decided that
to take that whole sentence out is that
correct
um i believe yeah you had mentioned that
to me uh replied that when it when it
came to you that line was missing and
you knew it had been there originally
yeah and i wanted to back in
so i put it in there and then i'm sort
of like uh told by the senators that
have been involved with this thing
you've got to be careful with that with
i i if that will be an issue
this
um and from my end i you know this is
certainly a compromise of it's informing
students we we'd like you to go
um so
yeah i think it's important it
encourages them to go
to school districts to figure out how to
do that
but i i um i hadn't been aware when they
when it was pulled out originally and
senator waters never mentioned anything
to me so i'm
i'm
now just curious as to what happened on
the senate side that they didn't like
the word students have a right it's some
of the language that initially came when
you were working with the council
and we were going through all those
yes
that helps out are there any other
questions of eric right now
um represent porter you have a question
all right just my
lack of attention i'm sorry
okay
okay uh
we need eric any further
thank you very much eric all right thank
you all for this
yep
thank you any further discussion on um
lisa is your hand up for part two there
uh no it would just be to follow up on
part three
i did or part one rather sorry i did get
an answer okay let us finish part two
here first then we'll come back to you
okay no problem
welcome
okay uh not seeing any further hands uh
madam kirk can you please take the role
on on part two
yes uh this is ought to pass on 1563
h
uh representative cordelli
yes
representative bone yes representative
notter
yes
representative
representative moppet
yes
representative hobson yes
representative andrus yes representative
ford
[Music]
yes
was that representative board i heard it
was
thank you
uh representative milor yes
representative lono yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
representative tanner yes
representative ellison
yes
representative mellon
representative porter
yes
representative woodcock
representative ladd
yes
20-0
thank you barb um what we'll do now is i
want to while lisa's here can you lisa
if you have any information uh
no response to some of the questions
that aren't allison brought up i
appreciate it
uh yes uh the follow-up was around
whether medicaid for schools would pay
for
you know hearing devices and i did get
confirmation from special education that
they would in fact pay for those
services if it was requested and ordered
by a school uh psychologist
or a school i'm sorry let me let me
actually read the language
a speech language and hearing services
hearing services shall be covered if
there are services supplies or equipment
ordered by a licensed audiologist or
licensed speech language pathologist to
be medically necessary for the student
due to their communication disabilities
so that is in fact allowed there
um
the other thing i just wanted to mention
was
if this wasn't repealed
we would have to work with the
lba because this was also part of our
audit in terms of
um
you know amending or or changing
repealing these sections that were no
longer covered by vr so i did just want
to mention that again
thank you very much i know
representative dwyer is going over that
audit here in another week and a half or
so
um are there further questions of lisa
thank you very much lisa thank you thank
you to the committee
thank
you okay um going on then uh to part
three
mr chair yes
could i could i make up like what's the
term a point of personal privilege
on this because i i am
would that be all right yes yeah
thank you very much rick so we've got
we've got two amendments i think looking
at um
at part three um 1586 and
1585.
um
what you're offering uh with
representative cordelli
um
looks to change the the um the focus of
this
to expand it very broadly to um to
encompass co-curriculars
um
keeps it specific to sports related
injuries but it does take into
consideration
um some of your uh comments
rip rick particularly definition of
sports
and and privacy concerns but it doesn't
lose fidelity towards the very very
specific nature of sports injuries
and and
and the number of incidents
that happened in sports compared to
other co-curricular activities and i was
wondering if maybe this would be one
area where we could unify on the idea to
pass um
the sports keep it keep it focused on
where it is
um
given the given the support from from
the corey stringer institute and other
you know national trainers associations
and uh and then look to maybe broaden it
um to other um
uh co-curricular activities even though
i think there are there is something in
the statute already that says schools
have to have emergency plans in
place for other things but for the sake
of our athletes
um and frankly all students and and you
know i was in the very very unfortunate
position
um and this time it's not a story about
being a ski coach having to take a kid
with a broken leg off the mountain but
a student from
basketball player from claremont
collapsed
on our gym floor in hopkinton um with a
cardiac arrest
and
um so it does happen um i just don't
want to lose the fidelity
yup we know injury does occur and
sometimes it's horrific
um
are there questions from the committee
regarding
everybody should have a copy of both
these amendments
um
there are some differences of course
um the differences i read of course
the one that represents presenting is
much
more narrow than the other where it
deals with
we've usually used the words curricular
and not a non-curricular in the past
or intramurals
if it's going to involve grades 4
through 12
the scholastic program
it's usually an activities program
sometimes they don't really call it that
so it's just a matter of terminology i
guess the other changes which i see is
that you have in their
specific reference to various
associations
and pre-participation examination
developed by the american academy of
pediatrics
and i would have questions on that
usually you know to get into sports
right now especially high school sports
you have to have a doctor's clearance
and there's a doctor's statement where
they put you through the fiscal
examination
that's for all kids and that's put out
so i see those as the major
major
differences uh there's
you also reference american college of
sports medicine and national astronaut
trainers association
um
uh in in the last you know in roman two
i see those as differences
yeah i think i i think those are the
the changes
are being offered
and um and you know some of the things
that i think we um
you know thought best to to leave in
there were basically references to the
best practices
that uh that that
schools across the country are adopting
uh when it comes to sports related
emergencies
and um you know rather than trying to
you know um
you know keep our statutes
um
up to date with with changes in best
practices relying on those national
institutes
to um
to provide the guidance there and we do
that in so many sections of the law so
that we're not rewriting laws all the
time um
but but i guess you know what i'm asking
is is if we could avoid the the
doing both amendments um
uh and and uh and you know
really look to to
you know keep it focused on on you know
what was what was uh what was heard uh
in the hearing in the house and senate
and um
and uh uh and maybe you know agreeing to
to bring something
uh new back next year
that
might add some language to to broaden it
in other areas but but you know less um
you know areas where there's less less
frequency of the impact of student
health
so so dave let's uh before we make a
motion on any one of these things let's
uh open this up to discussion with the
committee at this time
so representative bowman i see your hand
what's up yeah thank you okay i think
co-curricular better define mr
thank you for watching
these kind of occur i was just thinking
of the robotics
definitely could be some
injuries there and i think it means the
same type of uh
i mean nobody may be robotic to shape
and machine hit somebody um
so i think no curriculum i think the
better we need to cover
everything and other things happening in
the schools
from other
non-sports things but uh
even though in science lab and stuff
like that and chemicals uh i think
represent
your hand up
uh yes uh i think i have a little bit of
a
unique perspective on this having
coached for 35 years and
and
being a emt at one point and
teaching first aid for a long time
first responder first aid and cpr
aed
um sports offer
uh more risk
involved than
and and the number of injuries involved
with sports whether they're minor to the
cardiac arrest that that happened at
hopkinton
they're they're more frequent everybody
knows that when they
are involved in sports there's an added
risk
and a lot of times
those playing fields and
gymnasiums and our practices were late
at night or sunday morning or
you know um
just not during the regular school hours
where
a lot of the co-curricular activities
take place usually
right after school where there is still
staff in the building
and there is a bus for them to go home
whereas sports teams often
you know sometimes we're in remote
locations
so i think that
uh the the
the probability of somebody jumping off
a stage and breaking a leg in theater
even though they say it all the time
probably isn't
near as much of a risk as it is in
field hockey or skiing or football or
even soccer i mean
over the years i've i've witnessed um
you know a major break of a
of a humorous uh femur break
collapsed lung
sternum separation from ribs
we've had a cardiac arrest that i worked
on um
you know it was just
really important that we had a plan and
that we were connected to the local fire
and rescue people
and kearsarge is located out in the
middle of nowhere so you know we we
realized we had to be pretty independent
um
all our
plans though we're not necessarily
shared with the other fire departments
and emergency groups um it's it's been
since columbine it's been kind of
progressing how
emergency plans are done
but this this bill this part of the bill
is
to me very important because not only
does it set up a plan and get the
schools on board and we know with
emergency plans rick you know
that a lot of schools were reluctant to
do it um and
or file it with the state but i think it
it's really important they have a plan
for athletics
uh that they have um statistics taken
for these groups like the pediatric
group and the athletic trainers that
that's important for them
to get statistics and it's also
important for them when they set up
conditioning programs and programs for
coaches to train coaches how to deal
with program uh different areas and
particularly like heat stroke that's
that's a real biggie you may think it is
it isn't but that's a real biggie in
august
and it's becoming more of a biggie
as our heat and humidity you know get
higher in august when the football
soccer the fall seasons field hockey
start start really running off
so i hate to see this bill watered down
i think
dave is right we we need to keep the the
um basic
part of the bill
um i agree with with uh some of the
reporting needed to be changed but
um you know robotics uh theater art
music
um math team
those teams uh have lower risk
usually within the building or in a
building and should have a nurse a
school nurse on board during the day um
or a health person
that that takes care of that and usually
there's people identified on the
teaching staff
who have been trained
so um
i would i really um am passionate about
this i think i think we need to keep it
with sports so thank you
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman um
just a question about something i just
heard from the representative
uh
mentioned something about statistics for
the national trainers association and
college of sports medicine i don't see
anything in here about providing them
information
i'm just wondering if i'm missing
something or
comments are you asking me
uh
yes or anyone else if i if i missed
anything there i don't see anything
about providing information to the
i thought there was um
uh
the the policies
um let's see
i thought some of it was
i'll go back through it but i i thought
there was a part where
there was
procedures and and um statistics that
were kept on hand
for what had happened
i i know it i know at our school
whenever there was an accident
uh we also had an accident report we had
to fill out
um that was filed with the school
and um
but i think this uh you know has a
little bit more detail so if i missed it
i missed it sorry
no no i didn't if i can address that mr
chair
um i
in the in the amendment in 1585
um after the the um
the partner and i'm looking at the word
document that um i don't know if
everybody else has i i i did send out a
copy
of it but um
but after the section where it talks
about hipaa and ferpa the next sentence
which i think is what representative
tanner was referring to a comprehensive
history of information relative to
injuries
um that part is struck
um
you know it may be somewhere else in the
law but uh but we took it out of of this
due to the chairs concerns about um
privacy
thank you uh rep said uh
yeah mike lakes
yeah
i don't see expanding this to other
activities then sports waters it down in
any way it just says this is a really
good idea let's follow this up with
everybody else and i want to say i was
in the marching band
we practiced under the lights and we
were the only ones there we traveled
every place the football teams went
we had ankle and whatever injuries we
had heat stroke injuries
imagine being in your winter wool
uniforms that are designed for lasting
on a friday night football game in
november and being in a band competition
lined up for inspection we lost quite a
few students
who just dropped because they were way
overheated because it happened to be one
of those really hot spring days
and it was just as important
for us to know how to handle those heat
emergencies for that band and let me
tell you we were in some other town far
away
from home
when that happened so i think those
things are just as important and some of
the schools especially the agricultural
schools have forestry clubs and so
they're gone cutting wood and all kinds
of stuff um
in places that aren't anywhere near the
school and as far as theater i know
people who students who did theater and
they were constantly climbing up in the
rigging up above
and so a fall or whatever from there
can be pretty serious so i think it's
short-sighted to say no we're just going
to look at sports because sports are
more likely to have accidents
there are still accidents in other
things and not necessarily at school
right after school and so i think
expanding this doesn't water it down at
all it just says this is a good idea
let's make sure all our students are
okay
i got a question
does anybody know what the
pre-participate examination looks like
that's put out by the american academy
of pediatrics
um so representative miler i'm marissa
mr chair
yeah
um
there is somebody from the um the corey
stringer institute that's um in our
attendees and we may want to bring um dr
sternson to address that question
specifically and she has her hand up
okay can we
hello representatives thank you for
for acknowledging me
um and i can speak to the american
academy of pediatrics pre-participation
exam and i can tell you that it is
an exam that is open and freely
accessible online that's published by
the aap
and it is a standard exam that has been
adopted across many states
to
streamline the
pre-participation exam process because
depending on where you go for your ppe
many physicians who may or may not have
expertise
in the orthopedic injuries sustained by
athletes
have the knowledge and expertise to ask
specific questions that would be very
pertinent to the risks associated
with sport participation so
what this ppe does is it provides
guidance to ensure that all of those
components are included in the
thank you doctor can you tell me who
administers the ppe
yep um any um physician that an athlete
would
schedule their annual exam with could
for example if i took my child to my
child's pediatrician
that doctor would have that
participation examination there
they would have access to it or you
could
the athlete could bring it with them for
their exam
depending on many schools
because of the diversity in history and
ppes many schools will provide the
actual paperwork to the students and
they will bring that with them to
complete when they have their exam so
it could be accessed either by providing
it to the students or
it could be accessed for uh by the
physician themselves by going to the aap
website
okay i have one last question for you
doctor and then i'll open up the rest of
the committee
um
how different is this exam
from that which
schools are required to have their
you know before they can get into
athletics to have an examination from a
medical doctor
how different are the two examinations
so because there could be variants in
what is currently
being used across various school
districts and schools themselves i can't
speak specifically to that but all i can
say is that this
american academy of pediatrics
pre-participation exam
ensures that
the questions pertaining to the top
causes of
sudden death and sport are addressed so
it it addresses items
pertaining to previous head injuries um
previous heat injuries
if there are any blood conditions that
could predispose them to say an
exertional sickling episode all of those
are top causes of death in sport and so
it ensures that those components are
addressed in the history
questions that the physician is asking
which may or may not be included in
other exams
thank you um are there questions
of the doctor from other members of the
committee
not seeing any hands thank you very much
okay so we've uh
had some discussion regarding
and i think everybody now
knows the differences
um
[Music]
do we need any time folks to talk this
over
i wanted one more thing to okay mention
so um
something that i've noticed that we've
gotten in trouble with in the past
is putting into law the names of
organizations
because they changed their names
um and
came across that this year and something
i don't remember but
but the organization that was in the law
no longer still existed but had a
completely different name and so i'm
of actual organizations
in the law because
two years from now they may decide
they're not for instance american
college of sports medicine
but uh
some other similar
name just because the board of directors
decided this other name sounded better
so i you know i
referring to
somehow what best practices are without
actually naming names of organizations
just seems
better so we're not having to come back
and change them when they decide
they want to go by somewhat different
name
woodcock
thank you uh chairman
i just want to call on the general
process a piece of this part of the
building
having seen it both as an administrator
and
30 years as a coach in three sports
sport is uniquely
different
than other co-curricular activities not
suggesting in a moment all students
should be covered
all schools have plans but sport is the
only
organization we have for youngsters that
they have to take a free physical that
i'm aware of there's no pre-physical for
music for art for stem for robotics for
the forestry club that's not because the
unique nature of sport is inherently
more dangerous across the general
spectrum um so i'm just suggesting i
think in this particular case it's
important for us to hone in on the sport
factor and then if
because it's set up for the sport factor
um because it's more unique or risky and
then if we believe we want to expand it
to alcohol curricula
let's let's put down that get some
information from the the high school
folks
i told you at one point that dog will be
barking sorry um in either case the the
the other the other co-curricular
activities could very well be integrated
in a broader picture uh in the future
and we can go back to the nhia the
activity section and have them bring
something forward uh and as a school
principal association as well i'm i'm
just thinking this time this is specific
for sport because it requires a
pre-examination it is inherent in injury
um and we should facilitate i think that
this document singularly on that part of
sport interest and go back to the the
expanded core curricula at a future date
when we have a chance to get more data
on what would be best served
um thank you very much mr chair uh you
know uh we we we have had quite a bit of
discussion i know we could go into more
but i would like to move amendment 1585
for odd to pass
second
okay well we have a motion for
15.85 on the table made by
representative and second by
who is the
woodside
okay
is there further discussion on this
thank you mr chair
it's not that important
okay so we have a motion on the table
relative to
uh 15
85.
who suck at it i didn't hear one second
did it
griffs
who sent me the cutest card today i love
it thank you
okay
this is about to pass
i think we should remember too that if
we pass both of these
when they when they put them in they'll
just stick in
everything that's not in one they'll
stick in from the other one remember
that
somebody told me that a long time ago
okay uh this is for um
representative cordelli
no
representative boom
representative notter
no
representative lycus
representative moppet
representative hobson
no
representative andres
representative ford
no
nope
representative miller
yes
representative luno yes
representative shaw yes representative
cornell yes
president tanner yes
representative ellison
yes
representative mullen yes
representative porter yes
representative woodcock yes
okay i i i recognize uh represent
leicester's promotion
yeah i'd like to move the adoption of
amendment
1586 h
as otp
and uh griffs and hobson seconds it
mosh was made by representative
leicester second by representatives and
represent like us to speak your motion i
think i pretty much covered everything
in the earlier discussion
representative hobson i will refer to
brexit's testimony
represent porter
here so if i'm understanding correctly
with this um amendment that we're
working on now we're giving school
districts another
um assignment to work up emergency plans
for all their
co-curricular um
and
um
other
non-sports activities is that correct
yep they're all spelt uh there in uh
section one
or two hundred
and forty c
18 through 23.
so be sports and non-sports
right so all of these organizations now
within the school are going to have the
assignment to work up an emergency plan
the chess club
and the and the
chorus and those places they all have to
work up a plan that has to be on file
with the department of education the
school board has to know not the
department of education school board has
to develop the policy
and that's where it goes and then you
list each school plan shall include the
following documents and they're all all
whatever the number goes to
okay thank you there's no funding right
there's no funding to help with this in
any way
the other
volunteer time
the other bill had to do the same thing
for the sports teams well the other bill
provided best practices
thank you i'm just i'm just curious i
just i thought before we had had a
discussion about not forcing schools to
do something
um and now we're forcing schools to do
something so i'm just
asking
further discussion
president
yes
represent your
thank you thank you representative uh as
i read this more closely on uh
the intro i was wondering why uh
charter public schools is not included
if we're going to full curricula i
understand most chartered public schools
a limited number of athletics but if
we're going to full co curricula i would
i mean if support enough for a public
school co-curricular to be seen public
well we're talking about public schools
here in charter schools our public
schools i understand that it says online
18 on the amendment says local school
school school districts don't control
school boards for charter schools
i don't know why charter schools if it's
that important that the
every single co-critical activity has it
then it should include china public
schools
great so noted
further questions
well can that be changed or just you're
yeah
thank you mr chair um so uh i uh you
know with all due respect i don't
believe the amendment that's on the
table right now
is um
uh provides um uh the uh anywhere close
to the same level of
of of protection for um for you know for
students in the event of of sports
injuries as either the prior amendment
uh we considered or the the baseline um
part
three part three in senate bill 148
and um and so i think if we're if we're
really interested in in um in
in uh uh
prov or at least mitigating the um uh
the impact of um of injuries
that happen to
to students during
um interscholastic and intrascholastic
sports
then i think sticking with
well we we just lost our ability to go
to the um to the amendment offered
earlier but sticking with the
with the bill with section three in the
bill as presented from the senate would
uh what we're going to do for the whole
committee here right now we're going to
um
caucus
yeah we'll be
well let's well
different find there
mel you wanna won't caucus we'll caucus
okay
[Music]
where
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay
so for members of the committee out
there can you hear us
yes yes
okay uh
what we have done and what we're going
to go
forward with is that
in looking at
um uh the amendment 1586
we're
looking to have a change made
legislative services is working on it as
we're speaking
emergency plans for co-curricular
injuries
rather than for sports related
co-curricular related injuries versus
sport related injuries because that was
a conflict
and on line 18 a local board of each
school district or
public chartered school
or the governing body of each non-public
school shout
so those
minor tweaks but their significant
tweaks
are being done so what we're gonna do is
we're going to
not act on part three here right now
we're gonna jump to part four
and do part five and come back to part
three
okay
mr chair thank you for that modification
you're welcome
um
part four
relative to the definition of private
post-secondary career school
uh glenn representally do you have a
motion please yes i would like to move
on to pass
on amendment
and represent lancaster
i will check that now soon
represent like a second stop motion from
cordelia would you like to speak to your
motion please
uh yes thank you um
this amendment is very simple it uh
removes
uh
section n
from the original part four
from the department
that
that should satisfy
all the
[Music]
yoga studios and others um and that will
exempt
entities having a gross tuition under
100 000
uh from having to do the
surety bonds um but everyone else would
still be required to uh perform that
getting that bond
so i think that this amendment satisfies
sorry mr chair my hand should not be up
thanks very much mr chair um while i
think um
um
the um
the the section that
that
this amendment does retain
um uh part m
is is good
um uh i don't think uh unlike what what
representative cordelli said that it
that it satisfies all of the the
interests of the
companies that are businesses
around the state that are involved in in
fitness instruction including yoga
studios in fact we heard specifically
from their their um
a government affairs representative that
that it in fact doesn't so so
i would i would suggest that we leave
both the
parts
m and n
uh in there as presented in senate bill
148 from the senate in part four
and um
and that we
you know also refer back to the um
the
uh i guess the the specific support for
for both these uh pieces that was um put
forward by senator ward
uh as having a good you know basis for
thank you
welcome
yes i was wondering if someone could
enlighten me as to why
the second section is being removed i
wasn't here to hear what the objections
right it was explained by the department
and i asked a lot of questions about
this
so one of it is it singles out
particular businesses which we try not
to do
number two it doesn't actually say yoga
even though that's what it's addressing
number three
even when i did talk to the yoga people
they said yes the first one would
actually take care of all of their
people but they still wanted the second
one in
number four the department was afraid
that with this wording it would actually
um capture some people that we didn't
want captured
um and would make it broader and apply
to more than the intent
and he was not comfortable with section
m and was much happier
taking it out and leaving m in
and nobody could come up with anybody
can you tell me who he was that you just
referenced
you said no i don't need the name
what was the person representing
department of education steve applewood
thank you he's the one who's in charge
of handling this stuff so
it was his recommendation or his
agreement to
the my questions that yes he would
okay um
any further representative cardelli yeah
just uh i agree i my problem is that
this creates a special class of business
and us and uh
we have a
constitutional
language about creating special classes
of individuals and so forth this
which i understand we're not supposed to
further discussion on
uh
one five eight zero h amendment to part
four
[Music]
not seeing any hands up uh matt clark
this is ought to cast on 1580h
representative cordelli
yes
representative baum yes
representative notter yes
representative lancaster yes
representative moffitt
yes
representative hobson yes
representative andrus yes
representative board
yes
representative leon
representative saudi yes
representative miller
no
representative luno no
representative shaw no representative
cornell
no
representative tanner no
representative ellison no
representative mullin
no
representative porter
representative lad yes
9.
thank you
uh now moving on to part
are there any other amendments for that
section that i don't see
no
amendment relative to environmental
science and outdoor recreation as
criteria for inadequate education
okay representative
thank you mr chair i move that we adopt
amendment 1584 each with a
recommendation about the pass
okay uh
motion was made by
on the past this amendment uh
representative leon and second by
represent baum uh represent leon do you
have any pros of wisdom for us
yes thank you mr chair i hope that
they're pearls and not just pieces of
sand
which is important to the environment by
the way
so this amendment takes out what would
just be section law and while it does
give a nice narrative putting things
into section law it doesn't look around
and so it doesn't make sense
uh when we get down to the criteria for
inadequate education
um it amends it to say including
environmental sciences that investigate
the complex interaction of physical
chemical and biological processes that
take place on the earth and that second
section adopts the language that's
already been passed in uh one of our
other bills i believe in 242 but it's
been a long thing
when we look to those
we've discovered we've wrote in
committee many times about the
integration of skills and knowledge and
being able to bring together these
different areas of science in order to
understand the greater world around us
is beneficial to the students knowledge
and beneficial to our society so that
that change of both that focus gets to
the actual core of respecting and
understanding the world around us
when we get to section 2 here that is
the part that is amending the criteria
for science to include outdoor
recreation with actually sorry i
apologize it's already there
and in uh section seven
it it discusses the need to communicate
and participate effectively in a change
in society and environment because as
we've seen there are changes to the
environment we need to be able to put
things in context like uh the medieval
warming period and all of these
different time periods that have
impacted culture and society and
geographic boundaries and by being able
to
refer
and
thank you very much is there any
discussion
yes
yeah
you're welcome
further discussion on uh this amendment
on this amendment
promotion is ought to pass on 1584 h
representative cordelli
yes
representative boehm yes
representative notter
yes
representative lacus
yes representative moppet
yes
representative hobson
representative andres
yes representative ford
yes representative leon
yes representative soti
yes
representative myler
no
representative luno no
representative shaw no representative
cornell
no
representative tanner no
representative ellison
no
what's happening modeling no
representative porter no
who said woodcock you
represented lad
yes
ready
so now we're at a point where we're
having to wait for that amendment to
thank you mr chair i'm uh if i can have
a minute of personal privilege um
this is my sixth term as a state
representative and i have every term
asked to be on the education committee
um so i just want to tell you that i've
enjoyed being with you guys um you
people the last few days and thank you
for welcoming me into your committee
well thank you very much for the kind
words represent porter
you've certainly been able to engage and
be familiar with some of these topics
and from your finance side help us out
thank you
we've enjoyed your point of view
having been a teacher since day one
it just was kind of a natural thing
thank you president porter clearly did
represent hobson you have your hand up
yes i did i just wanted to i guess i
don't know how to do this take personal
privilege but i wanted to apologize
um i when i we were working on sb 44
earlier
i mentioned that the school board
association
and that's what i had on my handwritten
notes but as often happens when i'm
trying to let people in and out of
meetings it's possible i
made a mistake so uh jen four sent me
the notes
uh the minutes from that meeting and in
fact there was no uh statement from the
school board association so i just
so um
i hope that's okay did i do that
correctly all right
thank you for all that you do with the
technology you know we certainly
appreciate appreciate you as well
and i want to thank you
guys
well i wanted to say the barber you look
well we're just pleased to see barb home
yeah we are
um
can't believe i i can't believe i lasted
all day yeah
yeah you're looking good yeah good for
you some of us are really wilting here
at least i am i've run out of smoke
yeah it's really hot the air
is not working in the room here and
there's very little air flow even though
i can see some trees moving outside
way off in the distance
uh it's hot 180s in here
i'm glad i've got some good news for you
your amendment has arrived so you don't
have to wait
any longer
could you make sure you email that out
to everybody on the committee yep i just
sent it to the committee distribution
list
well thank you
what's the number on that amendment
16-25
so we had a motion on the floor
regarding the previous amendment
uh which was
1586 1586
so
um
let's see we the motion was out to pass
on that and it was seconded
uh so what we're gonna have to either go
through and vote that down
and then bring forth this amendment
i can recall i can also are you good are
you gonna leave all your emotions yeah
i'll just withdraw my mind so the
sponsor uh the nut spots but the person
who made that motion is uh
represent like us and she's pulling that
back and reps and hops and you did the
second you're going to pull that back as
well
so uh represent like us do you want to
make a motion on this new amendment
we're receiving yes 16 25 16 25 i wanted
to make sure
16 25 each
i moved we adopt them at 16 25 each
second and represent hobson's uh seconds
uh
representative lightness do you need to
have that you have in front of you or do
you need to have it but i know what it
what it was because i wrote the bits
well what it says right there on the old
line 17 emergency plans for
co-curricular related injuries right
and then on line 18 of the old amendment
that we just uh withdrew
the local board of each school district
or charter public school board
or the governing body and on the goes
right so we just took in the
recommendations that were made in the
committee
and added them into here
um
basically it was a good good suggestion
so we took it
okay uh further discussion on the
amendment
not seeing anything uh
represented uh shot can you please call
the roll
on 16
there here we go
um
ought to pass on 16 1625
h representative cordelli yesterday
representative bowm yes
bertha m naughter yes
representative lycus
yes representative moffat
yes representative
um
bobson
uh yeah yes
representative andrus yes
representative ford
yes representative lyon
representative sodi yes
representative milor
no
[Music]
representative luno
no
representative shaw yes representative
cornell
no
representative tanner
yes
representative ellison
no
representative mullen
yes
representative um
porter
and representative woodcock new
and representative what yes
uh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
fifteen
okay
i
recognize representative cordelli for a
motion please uh thank you mr chairman i
would like to move
on
is amended for how let's keep doing that
senate bill 148
with amendments
for part 2
for part three
1580 for part four
and 1584
4.5
do i have a second
okay so we have a motion on the floor
to approve
senate bill 148
with the following amendments 1563 1625
not seeing any hands up on mountain
clerk when you're ready we'll go with it
what to pass as amended with those
amendments
okay
uh and that's for sb
sorry 148 correct yeah
yes
representative cordelli
representative bone yes
representative
knotter
yes
representative hobson
representative andres yes
representative ford
yes
representative leon
representative soti
yes
representative miler
no
representative luno
representative shaw
um
yes representative cornell
no
representative tanner
representative ellison
no
representative mullin
representative uh porter
no
representative woodcock no
12 8
okay thank you very much representative
shaw takes us down to the end of the
road as far as acting on our bills that
we possess
is there going to be a minority report
on that
well that's why it's going to go next um
we
yes guys can
who's going to write that minority
report
david and i will put it together
i mean
i'll put it together this one will be
from mel
[Laughter]
okay
yeah
okay i got one person down and represent
cornell you'll be doing it also
sure and i'd like to remind other folks
that if you were
involved with one of the parts making a
motion and if you have information
please contact
either the person on the minority side
of the majority side is writing it you
might be able to help them out a little
bit
um
that's that would be appreciated i'm
sure
okay well that gets us down to the end
of our business for today i want to
thank everybody for hanging in there
it's been a long time
and uh i'm sure everybody's ready just
uh
get some fresh air or
get away from an air-conditioned car
yeah
and so that would conclude our session
for today and i once again thank
everybody for participating and